this is jocko podcast number 324 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening also joining
us again tonight is jason gardner good
evening jason good evening echo your
name jacob
so we rolled in
uh we're talking about this book and a
middle of a dissection of the life of
colonel joshua chamberlain or general
joshua chamberlain the hero of little
round top
the 20th maine who did a bunch of other
things in his life one of the parts of
this book that jason we were talking
about
before we got started was this letter
from joshua chamberlain to governor
coburn
this is from
headquarters 20th maine
volunteers in the field july 21 1863 and
here's what joshua chamberlain says and
this gives you such a keen insight into
his leadership and leadership
dear governor
i embrace a rare opportunity namely a
day's halt within a few miles of our
baggage to write you in reference to the
affairs of our regiment in which i am
well aware you feel the deepest interest
in the first place allow me to thank you
for the honor you have done me in
entrusting my care in entrusting to my
care this noble regiment i trust i shall
be always worthy of the confidence you
have thus placed in me
i consider it an officer's first duty
to look after the welfare of his
men to this he is bound no less
by the responsibility which the
arbitrary nature of his power imposes
than by the regard he should have to the
interests of the service in which he is
engaged
my experience in several trying
campaigns has taught me
that the way to ensure the efficiency of
the army
is to keep the men in the best possible
condition
physically
and mentally
so
take care of your people and your people
will take care of you so we used to say
that about our
gear care of your gear and your gear
will take care of you because you know
you got your parachute you want to take
care of your prayers you got your dive
right you get your weapon you want to
take care of your weapon it'll take care
of you take care of your people and your
people are going to take care of you
without the people there is no mission
there is no mission yeah the uh that
balance which occasionally gets brought
up how do you balance you know what's
more important the people are the
missions well the the people
the people without the people there's no
mission
and if you have one mission that you're
gonna do
i guess you can
put the put the mission above the people
but you're not gonna be in that
situation
you're not
so the people come first
and by the way
this is important
if there is alignment in what you're
doing
what your mission is
should help the people
so when you're in combat and you're
going out and you're taking the fight to
the enemy well guess what now the now
you can win the war now you can get the
people home to their families now we can
protect the world from
fascism or from nazism or from the
imperial japanese army or from communism
that's what these things are doing so
when you're out there a soldier you're
taking care of your people by helping to
win the war those should be aligned
that's why you had disalignment or
unalignment in vietnam where people are
saying hey wait a second vietnamese
aren't doing anything to me i don't care
if this is communist or not it doesn't
affect me and so we're not aligned it's
a problem
some people the people that were saying
hey we believe in the domino theory we
think it's all gonna fall down we need
to stop communism here those people were
aligned and were proactively fighting
the war
some people weren't
same thing in a company if i am trying
to build a factory
so that i can take my people and put
them in a better situation where they
have better working conditions it's
gonna help
them if i'm trying to get my team to
sell more widgets well jason how many
widgets do you still only sold three
well hey jason you need to sell more why
well because i want you to be able to
save money for college for your kids oh
okay yeah so the better you do
the better we do the better we do
the better you do because by the way
when you sell more widgets
we and echo sells more widgets now we
can produce more widgets that lowers our
cost to produce now we can lower prices
so you can sell even more widgets so we
can so
the mission and the men should be
aligned the mission and the people
should be aligned the goals should help
if what i'm doing is saying hey jason
sell more widgets and you say why and i
say because i want to
line my pockets more
what we're not aligned
we're not aligned but if i'm saying hey
sell more widgets so we can lower the
price point so you can have more job
security so you can
you know buy get a down payment for your
house all those things we want things to
be aligned when they're not aligned
that's where we have problems
taking care of your people is not
letting them
come in late and leave early
or or letting them fall short of the
standards and
and so that that's really interesting i
i like how hot worth broke it out and i
think in the last chapters of steal my
soldier's heart where he's warning guys
about being popular and folks want to be
popular ah yeah i'll just let them smoke
cigarettes because they want to smoke
cigarettes on watch and then
they get killed
being popular is not taking care of your
people and when you try to maintain a
standard
you're making them better people by
bringing them up to a standard it helps
them
it helps them
stay alive the the contrary to that is
or the opposite dichotomy of that is
hey i'm just going to impose my rules on
these people they're not going to know
why they're not going to know how it
helps them they're not going to know
that smoking in a in a watch position at
night can get you killed by a sniper
so instead you just mandate these rules
and if you hey i don't care if i'm
popular or not that's not a good
attitude to have if you're not look you
shouldn't be doing things to be popular
but if people don't like you that work
for you that's also a problem
that's also a problem and if that what i
just said makes you shudder a little bit
and think you know i'm not sure if i'm
on board with that you need to check
yourself quite frankly you need to check
yourself
i haven't worked for a leader that was a
good leader where everyone said yeah i
don't like that guy
they might say something like hey man he
can be a bit hard
but
he makes sense but he's doing it for the
right reasons but sometimes we're a
little bit too slack
the the the leader that hey we all hate
him but we're gonna do what he says
doesn't really exist man
no at least you're not gonna do it to
the best of your ability right when i
think about all those leaders that i
worked hard for
because
i was like i worked hard for this leader
because i was worried he was going to
yell at me yeah he got this much effort
out of me the leader that i worked
hardest for was the person that i was
terrified of disappointing
like delta charlie yeah yeah and del and
why
why in the world was i terrified of
disappointing delta charlie in in in
every other leader that i put in that
category
it's because they treated me with
respect
that's all you got to do so treat
everybody with respect and then your
life is going to be that much easier
especially your subordinates because
they're going to work hard for you
because they'll be terrified of
disappointing you yeah
and then okay
what if they're just going to take
advantage of you guess what there's
going to be some people that are going
to try and there's going to be you got a
team of 20 people there's gonna be two
or three of them that are looking to cut
corners looking to slack off that's true
it's true in a sealed platoon for crying
out loud in a sealed platoon where they
go through hell week and they go through
buds and they're highly selecting all
that stuff yeah some of those people get
to a platoon they don't want to do [__]
you know
they want to freaking corners they want
to go home early they don't care that
that's what happens you get those guys
in a platoon and they're not gonna they
might not commit hanging offenses
right they might not like skip work or
you know leave their weapon unattended
or something like that which okay that
if they're that bad you can get rid of
them but they know where the line is and
they just they just tiptoe on that line
and so there's people like that
there's people like that in every
organization
and if you then
treat everyone in your organization as
if they're that person that's trying to
get away with what they can and that's
how you treat everyone you're not
treating with respect you're
micromanaging them and it's going to
come back and haunt you
what's so here's an interesting thing
it's like sometimes
sometimes i'm weak
and i'm that guy trying to leverage a
friendship
against the standard
and then then when when a leader's like
no bro you got to do it this way
i don't lose respect for them i'm like
jack stop being weak i'll get after it i
want examples bro
what's an example of that
oh that's a good one oh shoot any like
um
want to come in late oh yeah you know or
like uh
maybe maybe on this dive i should be the
the duck and here here's a secret for
everybody seals don't like diving
and so
guys will try and wiggle out of it and
find other things to do and stuff like
that and
and uh so i know times that i've tried
to wiggle out of a dive and then i'll
get that later that just all they got to
do is raise their eyebrows
maybe they say something like
bro yeah yeah really
that's like that story i've told about
delta charlie so delta charlie's a guy
wrote about leadership strategy tactics
he's a guy that i work for in my second
platoon you work for him at trade just
like everyone just uh universal
respect admiration and love for the guy
but we we had done a hydrographic
reconnaissance
it on red beach like with for the
marines and you know it's all nighter
freaking waves were huge we got our
asses kicked it's freezing we go back we
make the chart in the middle of the
night blah blah blah and then the
marines landed so we support their
landing and they didn't like their
landing it didn't go the way they wanted
it to someone's like we're doing it
again
so everyone went back to the ships and
they're like okay well seals you got to
do that hydro recon again and we're all
like oh whatever i mean okay so we
launched the boats and
we're kind of in the wall like we're we
have all the information
we've already done the charts we've done
the graphs
and
someone thank god it wasn't me
is like hey are we actually going to do
this recon
and delta charlie's like
well we don't have to
and then he says
but would that be the right thing to do
and i was like oh
i'm like i'm so glad i didn't say that
because no one wanted to do it it's
freaking freezing dude it's freezing
it's going to be a four hour evolution
kicking through the surf and like being
that guy and actually this wasn't me
because i was a radio man so i was in
the boat with the gps like marking our
spots so i wasn't the one that's gonna
suffer but the number
four man or five man that's getting
pounded by four foot waves for an hour
as we do a freaking
perpend or no parallel recon off the
flutter board line i hate to admit it
but i've had to herd
swimmer scouts in like three times
before i actually rolled out of the boat
because i didn't want to because it was
so cold this room scouts in
can we get a little closer little closer
get in okay
uh
so that's why we take care of our people
that's what we're talking about with
this incredible leader
joshua chamberlain there's a bunch of
examples too where
we'll hit up where you're just treating
his guys with the most respect yeah and
and i mean just look at the way on the
last podcast we talked about the way he
treated mutineers
the way he treated prisoner mutineers
with respect listen to what they had to
say said okay i got your back and as
soon as he said he was going to take
care of them they took care of him
so
take nothing else away freaking take
care of your people
um
going back to the book here this is this
is from uh where he starts talking about
military operations on the white oak
road
the operations of the fifth corps on the
white oak road and once again this is
after he's coming back from
five months of recovery and bear and
getting sent back from the line after he
got shot hip to hip arteries blowing
apart he's just stuck away yeah and then
it gets hospitalized gets sneaks away to
get back to the front
um
fifth core on the white oak road 31st of
march 1865.
were more serious in purpose and action
than has generally been understood
he says and and again we're trying i'm
trying not to try i'm trying not to
talk through the entire scheme of
maneuver on these things
it's much easier to do that visually
than through the audio
format
but just to give you some general
understanding of the scenario
lee's army
during the previous winter had become
much weakened by lack of supplies
desertions and general demoralization of
the confederate cause and grant was
determined to take decisive measures to
break the whole confederate hold on
virginia
he planned a vigorous movement to cut
lee's communications and also those of
richmond and at the same time to turn
the right flank of lee's entrenched line
before petersburg and break up his army
again the reason we're still talking
about petersburg which we talked about
on the last podcast is because that's a
nine months of entrenched warfare of
trench warfare
the scope of grant's intentions may be
understood from an extract from his
orders to sheridan
so now we're talking about general grant
on march 28 1865 he says the fifth army
corps will move by vaughn road at 3 a.m
tomorrow morning the second moves at
about 9 a.m move your cavalry as at as
early an hour as you can and passing
to or through dinwiddie reach the height
and rear of the enemy
as soon as you can
it is not the intention to attack the
enemy in his entrenched position but to
force him out if possible
should he come out and attack us or get
himself where he can be attacked
move in with your entire force in your
own way
and with the full reliance that the army
will engage or follow the enemy as
circumstances will dictate so the reason
i wanted to point out this order is
because think about this is really good
decentralized command hey do this in
your own way figure it out i don't care
and we'll back you up cover and move
i shall be with you on the field and
will probably be able to communicate
with you
that's that's not a great comms plan
i'll probably be able to communicate
with you
guess what
should i not do so and you find that the
enemy keeps within his main entrenched
line you may cut loose and push for the
danville road
if you find it practicable
i would like you to cross the south side
road between petersburg and berksville
and destroy it to some extent
after having accomplished the
destruction of the two railroads which
are now the only avenues of supply to
lee's army you may return to this army
or go into north carolina and join
general sherman so
very broad strategic guidance about what
he wants done plenty of decentralized
command happening there
it's good stuff
in his personal letter to general
sherman of march 22nd giving the details
of his plans for sheridan's movements he
adds i shall start out with no distinct
view
further than holding these forces from
following sheridan that's the only thing
he's trying to do like that's a great
this is when we talk about commander's
intent that's the commander's intent
right there i got no distinct view other
than holding these forces from falling
chair that's what i'm gonna do
but i shall be along myself and will
take advantage of anything that turns up
these are flexible
good plans
fast forward a little bit
our whole division had arrived at the
chapel the chappelle house
when at about noon my command was
ordered to retrace its steps by the
vaughan to the quaker road and push up
toward the salient of the enemy's works
near burgess mill
again if you want to pull out a map go
pull out a map and you can see exactly
what that means all the stuff is so well
documented forwarding the run and
forcing the position we soon developed a
strong line which had entrenched itself
as an advanced post to cover the
important point at burgess mill
after stubborn fighting for over two
hours involving a loss to us of 167
killed and wounded including some of our
most valued officers i don't know why he
doesn't he doesn't describe that battle
in much detail in this section
other than the destruction that was
caused including some of our most valued
officers and a much heavier loss to the
enemy
of whom more than 100
killed and 50 wounded with 160 prisoners
taken by a sudden counter charge fell
into our hands we pushed the enemy quite
back to the white oak road and into
their entrenchments behind it
on the 13th the fifth core relieved by
the second
moved to the left along boynton road
advancing
its left towards the right of the
enemy's entrenchments on white oak road
lee also apprehensive for his right sent
mcgowan south carolina brigade and
mcrae's north carolina of hillscore to
strengthen
bushrod johnson's division in the
entrenchments there
so again trying to set this up a little
bit for you
um
the precise details of these orders and
movements were of course
not known to general grant so the
general lee's got stuff going on which
you know just heard me kind of lay out
of course general grant doesn't know
what's what's happening
but enough had been developed on the
quaker road to lead grant to change
materially his original purpose of
making the destruction of the railroads
the principal objective of sheridan's
movements
at the close of our fight there grant
had dispatched sheridan
our line is now unbroken from appomattox
to dwin to dinwiddie
i feel
i now feel like ending the matter if
possible before going back i do not want
you therefore to cut loose and go after
the enemy's roads at present
in the morning push around the enemy if
you can and get onto his right rear the
movements of the enemy of the enemy's
cavalry may of course modify your action
we will act together as one army here
until it is seen what can be done with
the enemy so he's making some
adjustments to what his original plan
were still giving some you know
some statement that the enemy gets a
vote and you can modify your
what you're doing you can modify your
actions is actually what he says
and you know part of the reason i'm
going through some of these commands
because it's it's interesting to hear
what these orders were like
and
how they came across and the importance
of writing well
and being able to write things in a
simple clear concise manner that
everybody understands
so important it's also important to
realize
that
no matter how
clearly you think you articulate
something
the chances of that person having it and
understanding it in exactly the manner
that you wish to convey it
are not strong
which is again another
proactive reason to
maintain flexibility in what you're
telling people to do
and if you give them what the objective
is look it's a lot it's a lot easier for
me to tell you hey jason we're trying to
get to this hill over here
that's it's pretty har i want you to
seize this hilltop
it's hard for you to misinterpret what i
say hey go seize this hilltop you need
to go take that hilltop okay well you
know what you're doing now if i start
saying hey i want you to take that
hilltop and i want you to maneuver in
this direction plus i want you to set
this up over here now there's a bunch of
things that can get misinterpreted
yeah or
we need to lay artillery fire down on
this thing
get me to a good spot to lay artillery
fire and then i can choose the hilltop
that makes the most sense for me
yeah
so
simple clear concise
that concise piece
is a real thing when you start talking
too much and trying to convey too much
and there's a balance of course you know
like take the hill that might not be
enough if i say take the hill in order
to provide
artillery support to this spot now you
can make all kinds of things happen
communication
um fast forward a little bit my command
was the extreme left of our lines my own
brigade along the difficult branch of
gravely run facing toward aries
with the and that's another another
leader out here with gregory's brigade
which had reported to me for this
campaign
refused which is a term that meant bent
back at right angles so as to face
westerly along a country road leading
from boyden to clareborn road
and this is where we can start to get
into a little bit
it may seem strange that in such a state
of things warren should have been made
should have made the suggestion for a
movement to his front but he was anxious
as were all his subordinates to strike a
blow in the line of our main business
which was to turn lee's right and break
up his army
wet and worn and famished as we all were
we were alive to the thought that prompt
that promptness and vigor of action
what we like to call violence of action
would
at all events determine the conditions
and chances of the campaign
and if this movement did not involve the
immediate turning of lee's right in his
entrenchments it would secure the white
oak road to the west of them which grant
had assured sheridan was of much
importance and would enable us to hold
lee's right in check so that sheridan
could either advance on white oak road
towards us and burgess mill as grant
asked him to do or make a dash on the
south side railroad and cut their
communications and turn their right by a
wider sweep as grant had also suggested
him due late in the afternoon warren
received through general webb chief of
staff the following order
general mead
general mead directs
that should you determine by your
reconnaissance that you can gain
possession of and hold white oak road
you are to do so notwithstanding the
order to suspend operations today
so he's getting told okay if you go do a
reconnaissance this is what warren's
getting told go do a reconnaissance
if you think that
through your reconnaissance you can take
white oak road and you can hold it
then do it
unless we tell you not to do anything
today
okay
and
so this just turns into the biggest i
had a hard time like he's trying to
explain to us how much confusion was
going on there yeah and i was like oh my
gosh yeah and that's
trying to track the confusion and i'm
getting confused yeah
like i guess i didn't even need to say
like hey this is going to be confusing
and it's hard to track
even if you go watch the video on
youtube with the animated pieces from
forty thousand feet exhale showing you
you're still gonna have a little i'm
gonna i'm gonna watch that again wait
who is this over here
but so he gets told hey if you think you
can take it taken and this is
this is what uh
chamberlain writes
this gave a sudden turn to dreams
and that humiliation fasting and prayer
visions arose like prophecy of old we
felt the swing and sweep we saw the
enemy turned front and flank across the
white oak road sheridan flashing on our
wheeling flank cutting communications
inflating the claire-born entrenchments
our second core over the main works
followed up by our troops in the old
line seizing the supreme moment to smash
in the petersburg defenses scatter and
capture all that was left of lee's army
and sweep away every menace to the old
flag between us and the james river
mirage and glamour of boyish fancy
measuring things by its heart
daydreams of men familiar with disaster
drenched in famous but building as ever
castles of their souls above the level
river of death
what a way to say hey bro
don't get your hopes up too high
this is when your what is it your your
emotions outweigh your capability what's
that that term the capability don't let
your enthusiasm outrun your capability
that's what he's talking about here hey
if we if we go man we can
take white oak road we can freaking
cut the blinds we're going to do it all
we're going to win it all daydreams of
men familiar that's what's scary men
familiar with disaster these are
hardened combat veterans
and they're drenched and famished
but they build castles of their souls
above the level river of death
such a good warning to us
don't let your enthusiasm outweigh your
capability
it was mingled with feelings of
mortification apprehension and
desperation that in the very ecstasy of
these visions word came to us of
sheridan's latest dispatch to grant the
evening before that pickett's division
of infantry was deployed along the white
oak road his right reaching to five
forks and the whole rebel cavalry was
massing at that place so sheridan would
be held in check by them instead of
dashing up as was his want to give a
cyclone edge to our wheeling flank
grant's dispatch to meade transmitting
this was a dire disenchantment the nell
rang thus from this dispatch warren will
not have the cavalry support on his left
flank that i expected he must watch
closely his left flank
so
now we're getting told we're all excited
and now we're being told no you're not
gonna have any support
and this is this is the ups and downs of
war right the highs and lows of combat
it's go it's a nautica it's a go it's
not a go
although grant had given outward that
there should be no movement of troops
that day
lee seems not so to have
lee seems not so to have resolved
[Laughter]
so the enemy gets a vote hey we don't
think there's going to be any movement
this day lee didn't agree with that we
didn't lee wasn't part of that plan
driven to seize every advantage or
desperate ex
expedition he ordered four brigades
to move out from their entrenchments get
across the flank of the fifth quarter
and smash it in
we did not know this but it was the very
situation which grant had made for the
occasion for attacking ourselves it was
a strange coincidence but it was to both
parties a surprise
the enemy gets a vote that's what's
happening
this was the condition of things and of
mines when the advance ordered
for the white oak road was put into
execution aries advanced soldier-like as
was his nature resolute firm-hearted
fearing nothing in truth not fearing
quite enough
although he believed his advance would
bring on a battle he moved without
skirmishes skirmishers but in a
wedge-like formation guarding both
flanks
the enemy onset was swift and the
encounter sudden the blow fell without
warning enveloping ares
complete front
general hunting
says they were not expecting to strike
our troops so soon and that the attack
was not made by usual orders but that on
discovering our advance so close upon
them a gallant lieutenant in his brigade
sprung forth in the front of his line
waving his sword with the shout follow
me boys
whereupon all three brigades on their
right dashed forward into the charge
there's a little decentralized command
well that's the reverse of what
what happened on little round top right
they
do a bayonet charge they destroy a
numerically superior force because
they took them by surprise and here
there's the confederates doing it to
them they're like uh and actually you're
like oh well they didn't do it by the
normal they've gotten that echelon and
so
there's a little bit of complacency
there
which will always get you yeah that'll
always get you
luckily you got some
young lieutenant that sees what's
happening and says you know what i'm
gonna make something happen we're going
on the counter
follow me boys
winthrop was overwhelmed in his superior
and and his supports demoralized all he
could hope for was to retire in gourd
order meaning retreat that's what he's
hoping you'll be able to get out of
there this he exerted himself to effect
but this is not an easy thing to do when
once the retreat is started before a
spirited foe superior numbers or in the
flush and rush of success
so
there's a confederate
guy that the decentralized command and
just charged them right uh
yes
and then i just broke them the the
and now you've got the union saying oh
we got a retreat like we're screwed um
which is bad
and then he talks about worse yeah well
it's worse and he said he's this this
winthrop all he can hope for is that
they can get out of there like not
losing control and he says
he tries to make that happen
but it's not an easy thing when the
retreat is started before a spirited foe
superior number so there's more
confederates they're fired up they're
flush from having being like they got
momentum going on
and in vain the gallant denison strove
to stem the torrent a disabling wound
struck down his brave example and the
effect of this shows how much moral
forces have to do in sustaining the
physical
so you've got a gallon individual that's
trying to get to stop people from just
running away because if you just run
away you're going to take massive
casualties look if you retreat you're
going to take casualties but
to put it in very simple terms
if you don't cover and move as you
retreat you're going to get slaughtered
so you've got to say okay
you know platoon over here you guys laid
down fire we'll go back 50 yards then
we'll lay down fire for you you have to
do that if you just all get up and turn
tail you're gonna get shot in the back
and you're gonna get slaughtered
so he's the leadership is trying to
trying to make that happen trying to
make it an orderly retreat
and this this individual
is stepping up trying to like okay hey
platoon hold and all of a sudden he gets
shot
and then he says that the this effect
shows the moral how much more the moral
forces have to do in than sustaining the
physical so
when that happens
it just falls apart brigade after
brigade broke in that instant brigade
after brigade broke that strange impulse
termed a panic
took effect and the retreat became a
route
aries
like a roaring lion
endeavors to check the disorder and make
a stand on each favoring crest and
wooded ravine butt in vain his men
stream past him
so he's every time he gets a little
terrain feature aries steps up and hey
hold up hey let's get some cover fire
they just run by him
they come back on crawford's veteran
division and burst through it in spite
of all the indignant kellogg can do
involving this also in the
demoralization and the whole crowd comes
back reckless of everything but to get
behind the lines on boynton road
plunging through the swampy run breaking
through griffin's right where he
and barlett reform behind the third
brigade
so finally they run back behind friendly
lines the enemy pursuing swarm down the
bank opposite us and are met by sharp
fire of musketry and artillery which we
had made ready on hearing the noise the
retreat
so once
the people that are retreating get
behind friendly lines union lines
now the the enemy is coming after them
and they engage
we are expecting them to fall in force
on our left in gregory's front when i
was riding along that line anxious about
this when general warren and general
griffin came down at full speed both out
of breath breath with their efforts to
rally the panic-stricken men whose honor
was their own and evidently under great
stress of feeling so now you got general
warren and general griffin come down on
their horse they're out of breath
and and they're trying to rally the guys
because it's their guys he says whose
honor was their own it's their guys that
are retreating
griffin breaks forth first and after his
high proof fashion general chamberlain
the fifth core is eternally damned
i have saved some pleasantries
not until you are in heaven
griffin does not smile nor hear but
keeps right on i
i tell warren you will wipe out this
disgrace and that's what we're here for
hey it's all on you bro it's all on you
chamberlain
we're we're we're damned
[Music]
then warren breaks out with stirring
phrase but uttered as if in delirium of
fever general chamberlain will you save
the honor of the fifth corps that's all
there is about it
that appeal demanded a chivalrous
is a mighty sentiment and the fifth core
was dear to me but my answer was not up
to keynote i confessed that i was
expecting every moment an attack on my
left flank now that the enemy had
disclosed our situation and my little
brigade had taken the brunt of things
thus far but the day before the last
winning a hard-fought field from which
they had come off grievously thinned and
torn and worn and whence i had hardly
but fought myself that day
or sorry but i had hardly brought myself
away so he barely made it off the last
battlefield and we already talked about
his casualties he didn't talk much about
the previous battle but
they had already taken
a couple hundred or almost a couple
hundred casualties and he barely made it
off i mentioned bartlett
who had our largest and best brigade
which had been but little engaged
we have come to you you know that you
know what that means
i'll try it general only don't let
anybody stop me except the enemy
it's right on yeah
so they've been put in check a bunch of
times you know hey hold what you got not
just in this battle but there's some
specific uh moments when that happens
where they're getting held back held
back held back
and he says you know i'll try but don't
let any anybody stop me but the enemy
i had reason for that
protest as things had been going on
they say back to him i will have a
bridge ready here in less than an hour
you can't get men through this swamp in
any kind of order says warren
it may do to come back on general it
will not stop it will it will not do to
stop for that now my men will go
straight through so they want to bring
like one of those pontoon bridges down
chamberlain hey in an hour we'll have
your pontoon bridge otherwise you can
knock me to do it
that'll do to come back we'll come back
on that bridge when we're done
so out of word
the first battalion of the 198th
pennsylvania major glen commanding
plunges into the muddy branch waist deep
and more with cartridge boxes born upon
the bayonet sockets above the turbid
waters the second battalion keeping the
banks beyond
clear of the enemy by their
well-directed fire we got cover and move
going on by the way
until the first has formed in the
skirmish order and pressed up the bank i
followed with the rest of the brigade in
the line of battle and gregory's in
column of regiments
the enemy fell back without much
resistance until finding supports on
broken strong ground they made stand
after stand griffin
followed with bart bartlett's brigade in
reserve
in due time aries troops got across and
followed up on our left rear while
crawford was somewhere to our right and
rear but out of sight or reach after we
had once cleared the bank of the stream
after sharp fighting here we drove them
across an extensive field to some works
they seem to have already prepared
of the usual sort in field operations
logs and earth from which they delivered
a severe fire which caused the right of
my line to waver taking advantage of the
slight shelter of a crest in the open
field i was preparing for a final charge
when i received an order to hold my
command and defend my position as best i
could
i did not like that much it was a hard
place to stay in the officer who brought
me the order had his horse shot under
him as he delivered it
so here you are you're ready to make a
charge and also they say hey what you
got
and by the way the person that's telling
you to stay there just had his horse
shot out from under him
i wrote back to see what the order meant
i found general griffin and general
warren in the edge of the woods
overlooking the field and reported my
plans we had already more than recovered
the ground taken and lost by the second
and third divisions the fifth quarter
had been rapidly and completely
vindicated and the question was now of
taking white oak road so they've gotten
back all the ground the fifth core yay i
we delivered
you wanted me to rectify the honor lost
by the brigade
by the core sorry we did it
and he says i propose to gregory to put
gregory's brigade into those woods by
battalion international on by the left
by which formation he could take in
flank and reserve in succession
my any attacks on my right when gregory
should be well advanced i would charge
the works across the field with my own
brigade
my plan being approved i instructed
gregory to keep in the woods so it's
another great example of pushback they
tell him hold he goes wait a second
they're not seeing something that i'm
seeing goes back and talks to his
leadership and says i got a better idea
how about this
yeah
and they say
get some
and the moment he struck any opposition
to oprah this is another part of the
plan was at the moment this was for
gregory the moment he struck any
opposition to open at once with full
volleys and make all the demonstration
he could and i would seize that moment
to make a dash at the works in my front
i known the fact that general lee
himself was personally directing affairs
in our front i might not have been so
rash or thought myself so cool so he
comes up with this plan and later he
finds all those general lee was going up
against damn
um
and now it gets down to business he says
what we had to do could not be done by
firing
this was foot and hand business we went
with a rush not minding ranks or
alignments but with open front to lessen
loss from long-range rifles within
effective range about 300 yards the
sharp cutting fire made us reel and
shiver
now quick or never
on and over
the impetuous 185th new york rolls over
the enemy's right and seems to swallow
it up the 198th pennsylvania with its 14
companies half veterans half soldiers
born so swing in from their left
striking hunting's brigade in the front
and for a few minutes there is a
seething wave of counter currents then
rolling back leaving a fringe of wrecks
and all is over
we pour over the works on across the
white oak road swing to the right and
drive the enemy into their entrenchments
along the clairbourne road and then
establish ourselves across the road
facing northeast and take a breath
there's a footnote in here
general hunting
since senator from virginia said in his
testimony before the warren court
speaking of this charge the charge that
he led the charge that that
um chamberlain led
i thought it was one of the most gallant
things i had ever seen
major woodward in his history of 198th
pennsylvania giving a graphic outline of
the last dash closes with an incident i
had not reported recorded
only for a moment he says did the sudden
and terrible blast of death cause the
right of the line to waver on they
dashed every color flying officers
leading right in and among the enemy
leaping the breast works a confused
struggle of firing cutting thrusting a
tremendous surge of force both moral and
physical on the enemy's breaking lines
and the works were carried
private augustus zebra
captured the flag of the 46 virginia in
mounting one of the parapets and handed
it to general chamberlain in the midst
of the melee who immediately gave it
back to him telling him to keep it and
take the credit that belonged to him
almost that entire regiment was captured
at the same time
it was scarcely
need
be added that the man who captured that
battle flag was sent with it in person
to general warren and that he received a
medal of honor from the government
so again the the representation of these
flags is
it means that and the fact that
zebra cat zebra is yeah
augustus augustus groot
zebra captures the flag and then he's
like hey man you got it you keep it
nobody misses that
nobody they're like oh that's the guy
that's that's letting the team have the
credit
and
they're that that's the kind of leader
that you're going to die for that you're
going to be afraid of disappointing
because he's pushing it
and there's just example
after example of him doing that kind of
thing
yep that's
literally
what you said it's the
the the flag the symbol of the enemy is
this thing this flag that's all the
credit that is the credit
and he and the the young soldier gives
him the credit and he says nope
you get the credit
[Applause]
in due time gregory came out of the
woods his face beaming with satisfaction
at the result to which his solid work so
faithfully performed had been essential
by the way this is just a giant covered
move gregory's over in the wood line
laying down fire as soon as they got to
a point where they had good angle he
they let loose the fire and that was
chamberlain's signal to go and they went
that's why there's no other
tactic that's it
his brigade was placed in line along the
white oak road on our right and a picket
thrown out close up to the enemy's works
this movement had taken three hours and
was almost a continuous fight with
several crescendo passages and a final
cadence of wild chromatic sweeps
settling in the steady keynote thrilling
with the chords of its unwritten
overtones and undertones
it cost us a hundred men but this was
all too great of men like these and for
oblivion
it was to cost us something more a sense
of fruitlessness and thanklessness
fast forward in a little bit
grant had experienced a sudden change of
mind
mind a complete and decided one
his imperative order now received meant
giving up entirely the position we had
just been ordered to entrench across the
hard one white oak road
and that
i mean after this it just turns into a
huge
mess which would take like three hours
just to try and
tangle
yeah um
and i guess a big example of it is just
really really poor communication yeah
information coming in at weird times
yeah we'll jump into that it's worth
jumping in that's that's one of the
reasons i kind of felt like i had to
sort of try and explain some of the
maneuver the schema maneuver um
so that we could when we get to the kind
of breakdown of all these orders that
were coming in when they came in it's
like and this is another one of those
orders which is hey
give up that what you just fought for
that's the fruitfulness that he just
talked about here's why
and it goes then it says warren anxious
to fulfill the spirit and object of the
order rather than render a mechanical
obedience to the letter of it sends his
nearest division under aries
the strong
stern old soldier of the mexican war to
start once at once for sheridan
sorry this situat this was the situation
when half past 10 in the evening came an
order throwing everything into a
complete muddle
it was from meade to warren send griffin
promptly as ordered by the boynton plank
road but move the balance of your
command by the road bartlett is on and
strike the enemy in the rear who is
between him and dinwiddie so now you can
see now the orders are becoming very
very specific
actually telling this person to go to
this place and do this thing
instead of letting the people on the
ground hey my intent is to get to the
rear of the enemy if you said that to me
cool i got a
group that's even closer or a group that
didn't take that many casualties or a
group where i got a super aggressive
leader he can make it happen but you're
when you give these very specific
micromanaging directions
you're going to impose things on that
you might not have intended it you know
who's the person best to solve the
problem the guy back in the tent or the
person closest to the problem
and that that's what you're empowering
those folks to do and you're like hey
here's what we need to do and then you
figure out yeah because it's just it's
all these specific orders coming in
flipping guys around yeah and if you and
if you
see something or know something from the
tent that the person in the front can't
know or can't see then it's your job to
inform them of that so that they can put
that into the calculus of their decision
making process
patton said the
well
done the exact quote but the leader on
the front is always wrong the leader in
the front is always right the leader in
the front is always right so you support
that guy
jason calls back and says hey i need air
support cool i'm getting your support
you tell me you need another platoon
support cool we're sending another
platoon i'm not saying what do you do
though
if i if you say hey i'm going to
maneuver to the north instead of the
south okay let me make sure you have the
support you need not will i actually
think it would be better to unless i see
hey jason there's a massive enemy force
coming in from the west you need to
steer clear there oh thank you for
telling me
another by this order the core was to be
turned and for end and inside out poor
warren might be forgiven if at such an
order his head swam and his wits
collapsed he responds thus and has been
much blamed for by those under his
canvas then since
i issued my orders on general webb's
first dispatch to call back which made
the divisions retire in order of ares
crawford and griffin which was the order
they could most rapidly move in i cannot
change them tonight without producing
confusion that will render all my
operations nugatory
i will now send general aries to general
sheraton and take general griffin and
general crawford to move against the
enemy at this last dispatch directs i
should i cannot accomplish the object of
the orders i have received
he says look dude i've already got
people in a certain order out here if i
start trying to rearrange them in the
middle of the night are you kidding me
no
but what inconceivable addition to the
confusion came in the following dispatch
from general mead to warren at one
o'clock at night would not time be
gained by sending troops by the quaker
road again this is my bad micro
management happening
[Applause]
one of the f one of the very first
uh
academy briefs that i did on the academy
was about i called it the whip
and oh yeah i talked about
we were but we were on the ark so we're
on a ship
and we're supposed to be doing some
training mission
and we get told hey you're going to take
your zodiac boats and load them on a
helicopter and
and go do this mission okay cool so what
does that mean
it means about
four or five hours of preparation
zodiacs we got to get the the mo gas
fuel to the right part of the ship we
got to get the the
the um equipment prepped and loaded into
the zodiacs then we got to get the
zodiacs moved to up to the hilo deck and
then we and we got to tie them all up
with all that freaking
10 000 feet of half inch and one-inch
tubular nylon put the honeycomb
cardboard into the bottom and put pack
the freaking engine into it like there's
this massive amount of work
and we're doing it
and then we get word hey actually you're
not going by hilo you're going by
rib boat rigid home inflatable boat
okay
so we start breaking all that stuff down
it takes us another five hours to break
it down and get these zodiacs ready to
launch with the ribs
just as we complete that task what comes
back actually it looks like it's going
to be helos so this is some i've lived
that same thing oh it's a nightmare and
i call it the whip because it's a little
tiny movement up at the top it's just a
little oh we're gonna use helos okay he
literally changes one word in a brief
insert by helos insert by rip changes
one word in this little briefing takes
him four seconds
and it costs us five hours of work
and then
very quickly changes it back to ribs
back to helos and so as leaders we have
to understand the impact that the little
movement you have from the top takes on
the bottom
who corrected that
uh i think we like dlr'ed on the like
fourth change
like no actually it was
uh i think my platoon commander was like
hey we we don't have time we can't
actually do that the only thing we can
do is launch on whatever it was i think
at that point it was on ribs we can't
get we don't have time to get helos
ready what do you mean enough time it
takes five hours to rig four boats for
freaking
god
yeah it's interesting and that's
one of those things where dude i just
raised your breath i just raised your
blood pressure
there's
because i've i've lived right
like somebody comes out of this
air-conditioned space where they're
doing it and they're like i live that in
guam it's like hey we're going to do a
stack duck
and we get all the way to where we get
the jump master to come to a stackduck
is when we have
we're going to jump two zodiacs via
parachute and the rest of us are going
to parachute and then it turns into
the limp duck where now it's not going
to get parachuted in but it's just going
to get pushed out the back of the
helicopter it's got to get re-rigged
completely and everything changes and
you're just getting flailed around
and
and that's when mistakes happen and
that's when it's good that like
hopefully there's somebody in there
in in the decision-making process it's
like hey you're jerking everybody around
right now that's detached because the
guys that are they're making these calls
they don't realize it they're just
coming up with a bunch of good ideas
and they've forgotten what's happening
at the end of the that whip that they're
waving around
continues on here rapidly changing plans
and movements in affecting the single
purpose for battle
for which battle is delivered are what a
soldier must expect the and the ability
to form them wisely and promptly
illustrates and tests military capacity
but the condition in this case rendered
the execution of these peculiarly
perplexing
orders had to pass through many hands
and in the difficulty of delivering
owing to distance and the nature of the
ground the situation was called which
called for them had often entirely
changed
hence some discretion as to the details
in executing a definite purpose must be
accorded to subordinate commanders
decentralized command thank you
the details in executing a definite
purpose the purpose needs to be definite
this is what we're doing the details of
execution let the subordinate commanders
do it
look for a moment at the summary of the
orders warren received that evening
even after we had reached white oak road
affecting his command in detail one
to send a brigade to menace the enemy's
rear before sheridan but he had already
but he had already a div of his own
accord set bartlett's brigade of
griffin's division the nearest troops by
the nearest way he already had that
problem handled
two send this brigade by the boynton
road instead of the crump this was a
very different direction and a very
different tactical effect but impossible
to recall bartlett warren sent pearson
already on boynton road with a
detachment of bartlett's brigade
three send griffin's division by boynton
road to sheridan and draw back the whole
court of that road griffin's division
being widely and far scattered and
impossible to be collected for hours
warren sends aries division nearest and
most disengaged
four to send aries and crawford by the
way of bartlett had gone and insisting
on griffin's going by boynton road this
would cause aries and bartlett to
exchange places crossing each other in a
long difficult and needless march
ares having gone according to warren's
orders griffin and crawford were to go
by bartlett's way
but griffin had sent for bartlett to
withdraw from his position and join the
division ready to mass on point road so
this is just
you can see why this is just mayhem it's
total mayhem and it's mam from
micromanagement is what it is mayhem
from micromanagement
it is difficult to keep cl keep a clear
head in trying to see this into this
model now we can imagine the state of
warren's mind
but this was not all
within the space of two hours a warren
received orders involving important
movements for his entire core in four
different directions these came in rapid
succession and in the following order
one to retrench where he was
on the wider white oak road and be ready
to fight in the morning this was from
grant to fall back with the whole core
from the white oak road to boynton
and send a division by this road to
relief sheridan this was also from grant
number three griffin to be pushed down
boynton road
but the rest of the corps aries and
crawford to go across the fields to the
crump road by the way bart
bartlett had gone and attacked the enemy
in the rear who's opposing sheridan this
was from mead
this required a movement in precisely
the opposite direction from that
indicated in the preceding order which
was now partly executed aries had
already started number four meade's
advice to send these troops back by
quaker road 10 miles around and give up
the rear attack number five to these may
be added the actual final movement which
was that ares went down the boynton road
and griffin and crawford went by dirt
road across the country to crump road as
indicated in meade's previous orders
there's one more thing general grant
thought it necessary in order to make
sure that sheridan would have complete
and absolute command of his troops to
send a special message asking me to make
that distinct announcement to sheridan
this is craziness
the orders which came to general warren
that night were to an amazing degree
confused and conflicting this is
charging no blame on any particular
person
we will call it if you please the fault
of circumstances
but of course
the responsibility for the evil effects
of such conditions must naturally
in military usage and ethics
rest upon the officer receiving them
when he is not allowed to use his
judgment as to the details of his own
command it makes it very hard for him
sometimes indeed it is not very pleasant
to be a subordinate officer especially
if one is also at the same time a
commanding officer
but
in this case i think the trouble was the
result of other recognizable
contributory circumstances if i might
not say causes so he's got some other
reasons why this stuff happened
this is just it's just mayhem
and he's he's in writing the most
articulate and eloquent case for
decentralized command and not
micromanaging
some of the reasons he says the
awkwardness of having in the field so
many superior rather than coordinate
commanders boom
it's a bunch of people make bunch of
chiefs no indians and it's not really
clear who's the main effort and i think
they shifted up at one point and you
called this a double objective
one point being sheridan's independent
operations to cut the enemy's
communications the other turning of
lee's right and breaking up his army by
the interview which one of those this is
prioritize and execute which one of
these is more important which one do you
want us to do
and by the way you can't just say both
because
both only works if the enemy doesn't get
a vote but the enemy's gonna get a vote
and so is weather and so is your troops
and so is morale and so is the supply
chain like all these things are going to
have an impact
so we got to know what's the most
important thing you want done
number three these supreme commanders
being at such a distance from the field
of operation on the 31st of march that
it was impossible to have a complete
mutual understanding when orders were
put into effect you're not up there and
you're making calls from the rear with
the gear
number four time lost and sequence
confused by the difficulty of getting
over the ground to carry orders or obey
them owing to the condition of the roads
or lack of them and the extreme darkness
of the night so yeah communication
problems
he says at three o'clock i had got my
pickets which were replaced by
crawford's and let my men rest as
quietly as possible knowing there would
be heavy burns laid on them in the
morning
so all this freaking chaos is going on
and by the way like
when that whip hits the freaking
infantry man that's out with his single
last shoes that are both made from left
freaking foot
god and he's lost four of his friends
and he's hasn't eaten and he's thirsty
[Applause]
after such a day and night
as that of the 31st of march 1865 the
morning of april 1st found the men of
the fifth course strangely glad they
were alive
they'd experienced a kaleidoscopic
regeneration they were ready for the
next new turn
the test of ordinary probation had been
passed all the effects of humiliation
fasting and prayer believed to sink the
body and exalt the spirit had been fully
wrought in them
at the weird midnight trumpet call they
rose from their fields as those whom
death no longer had any power
their pulling out for the march in the
ghostly midst of dawn look like a
passage in the transmigration of souls
not sent back to work out the remnant of
their sins as animals but lifted to a
third plane by that three days of the
underworld
eliminating
sense incorporating the soul there's a
word i had to look up transmigration
that's basically reincarnation so
they're getting reincarnated not as
animals
but lifted to a third plane
uh
there was an interesting note on here on
the term infantry
did you do the etymology of the word
infantry
don't know it
infant
yep the lamest etymology i'd ever heard
i was so bummed that i almost didn't
want to talk about it on the podcast
but back in the day
the infantry where the people that
weren't old enough or mature enough or
of high status enough
to to fight on horses
and so they're infants
they're the they're they're the babies
i didn't want to say this i can't i
can't not say it i can't say it's not
true
but that's where it comes from
because what does he say uh
sheridan had also come to the opinion
that infantry was a good thing to have
around however by some queer break in
the hierarchy of honor subordinated to
the chevaliers the biped meaning the
person to the
quadruped meaning the horse and by some
freak of etymology named infantry the
speechless
that's another thing like hey you don't
need to say anything you're infantry
the speechless whether because they
couldn't talk or because they mustn't
tell
sorry infantry troopers of the world you
have my utmost respect and i apologize
for the etymology of your name
it's horrible i have no idea what to
make of it
we'll stick with grunts
the troops what's that
uh
one of pressfield's book on on
afghanistan the afghanistan campaign
that one of the infantry guy goes you
know what we are we're mules mules that
kill yeah because all they do is walk
and pack gear that's a good one and then
fight
well the the uh
the dedication um in about face to all
the dough boys the ground pounders the
grunts
the american infantrymen there you go
boom
going back to the book the troops had
enjoyed about four hours
of this unwanted rest when the cavalry
having completed its reconnaissance were
ordered for it and by the way he talks
about this there's a march that they
take place that
they have to freaking march their ass
off to keep up with the cavalry horses
we who were trying to follow closely
were brought this is the talking about
the march we were trying to trying to
follow closely were brought to frequent
standstill this was vexatious another
good word for you
our men being heard to their feet in
heavy marching order carrying on their
backs perhaps three days life for
themselves and a pretty big heavy
installment of death and for their
antagonist and now compelled every few
minutes to come to a huddled halt in the
muddy road marking time and marking
place and also with deep discontent in
about two hours we get up to where
sheridan wants us i think it's crazy
to to that he
in this
in this elevated book
he still talks about the fact that it
sucks when you're walking and you gotta
stop and then you go and then you stop
and then you go and you stop and just
hurry up and wait
he even has to mention that
that it's vexatious to have that happen
uh
during this impatient waiting for the
seemingly slow preparatory formation our
spiritual wheels were lubricated by the
flow of discussion explanation about the
plan of attack sheridan took escape a
saber or scabbard and described it
graphically on the light earth so this
is the this is the classic hey he pulls
out his sword and draws in the dirt what
we're gonna do the plan in general is
for the cavalry to occupy the enemy's
attention by a brisk demonstration along
the right front of their works while the
fifth core should fall upon their left
and rear by a sort of surprise if
possible and scoop them out of their
works along the white oak road and
capture or disorganize them cover and
move
go ahead
and we're back to where he was yesterday
because yesterday they were holding
white oak road
and they got jacked around and drug
around and walked all the way around and
now they're right back to where they
started
it's amazing that they just didn't just
completely get pissed off and throw
their rifles down
roll up and there's all kinds of
confusion in fact he says ill at ease at
such confusion of mind i rode over to
general griffin who with general warren
was close on my left at the early stage
of this movement and asked for an
explanation griffin answers quickly we
will not worry about ourselves in
diagrams
we are to follow crawford circumstances
will develop our duty okay
well that's that's more helpful than
that diagram they're about to get right
uh
they're starting to move he says i
halted my line and rode ahead through
the woods to some high cleared ground
the southeastern corner of a large field
known as sydnor field
along the opposite edge of which i could
see strong skirmishing along crawford's
front
and turning southerly looking across
broken scrubby ground could see aries
troops engaged in a confused world of
struggling groups
with fitful firing
so he's maneuvered into a position where
he can see what's happening
there was ares fighting alone
and that was not in the program meaning
that wasn't part of the plan there was
griffin down there that was an order
enough for me and i took the
responsibility of looking out for the
left instead of the right where my last
orders committed me
i pulled my my brigade out of the wood
by the left flank telling gregory to
follow and sending to bartlett to let
him know what i was doing
pushed across a muddy stream and up
through ravine toward aries halfway up
griffin came to meet me
never more welcome
he gave the look i wanted and without
coming near enough for words waved me to
follow up to the head of the ravine and
to attack on my right
along the bank where hidden by brush and
scrub the enemy had a line perpendicular
to their main one on white oak road and
were commencing a slant fire in ares
direction griffin road passed me toward
warren and bartlett so
there's a bunch of things going on there
number one he had been told to do one
thing but he looks at what's happening
and decides i gotta do something else
and on top of that
he then he actually tells other people
hey i'm i'm i'm adjusting the plan here
so you know
i'm doing this i mean that's what right
looks like yeah that's what right looks
like and
again it's when you think about the
details he's writing this book the
detail that you just pointed out was
important enough to him to put it in
here to say uh i let him know what i was
doing
and you know when we mentioned on the
last podcast about gettysburg and
hey this guy took initiative it was good
this guy took initiative it was bad
what's the difference one of there's
several differences one of the
differences
oh i took initiative but didn't tell
anyone that's bad
oh i took initiative and tell people
what i was getting
getting to do
then that's good that's one of the
things that makes it good so
again you've got to pay attention to
what he's paying attention to
he's paying attention to all of us
telling us leaders hey when you're going
to change something you need to let
people know what you're doing
and then i just thought it's cool you
don't talk about relationships and sort
of like the silent leader just see the
guy look at him i got you the head nod
we're going
aries fitful fire was approaching and i
rode over towards it somewhere near the
angle of the works i met sheridan he had
probably seen me putting my men in and
hence i escaped censure for appearing
indeed his criticism seemed to be that
there was not more of me rather than
less
oh by god that's what i want to see was
his greeting general officers at the
front where are your general officers
i replied that i'd seen general warren's
flag in the big field north of us and
that seeing ares was in a tight place
i'd come to help him and by general
griffin's order
then
cried he with a vigor of utterance
worthy of an army and flanders you take
command of all the infantry around here
and break this dam
i didn't wait to hear any more that made
good grammar as it stood
i didn't stand for anything but spurred
back to some scattered groups of men
demoralized by being so far in the rear
and not far enough to do them any good
yet too brave to go back captain brenton
of griffin staff came along and i took
him with me down among these men to get
them up i found one stalwart fellow on
his hands and knees behind the stump
answering with whimsical grim grimaces
to the bullets coming pretty thick and
near look here my good fellow i called
down to him don't you know you'll be
killed here in less than two minutes
that would be a shame this is no place
for you
go forward
but what can i do he cried i can't stand
up against this all alone
no that's just it i replied we're
forming here i want for you to guide
center up and forward
up and out he came like a hero
i formed those reserves on him as a
guide in the whole queer line 200 of
them went in right up to the front and
like the thick of it
my poor fellow only wanted a token of
confidence and appreciation to get
possession of himself he was proud of
what he did
and so was i for him
freaking epic i got goosebumps from that
man
you know i i i tell that story i was at
trade ed and like the mount situations
going on and the guys are getting all
their ass kicked with paintball and
everything and no one's making any
decisions and i walked over to this one
badass e5
and
i looked at him i go hey bro i go what
do you think you should do right now
he's like we ought to freaking storm
that building over there and get some
freaking get some cover and i go
why don't you make it happen and the
look on his face i wish i had a video he
looked the look on his face was like
wait why don't i make it happen you mean
i can make this happen he goes hey
strong point that building immediately
everyone just did what he said
freaking i think he might have been a
new guy
might have been a one cruise wonder i'll
have to ask him because i know exactly
who it is he's an awesome guy but
just that right there i mean now this is
a combat situation dude you just give
that little bit of confidence
you take charge this is taking ownership
right when we talk about giving people
ownership you give them ownership hey
i'm gonna make you the center people
always ask us what do you do when people
not motivated give them ownership
this is the example
henceforth this is the example of giving
ownership i despise running despise it
you're not going to catch me running
unless i'm running toward a chocolate
cake or away from the police
right but if you tell me to lead a run
i can run somehow
it's like somehow it's like anyone who's
leading a run when you're doing a
conditioning run you're like man they're
really setting the space because somehow
you're buoyed up
by all those people behind you you own
it it's you yeah
general gwyn was riding up and down
their front in a demonstrative manner
but giving no sign of forward movement
i thought this strange for him and bad
for all of us
in the pinched things we're at
and with the warrant
sheridan had given me galloped down to
him and asked him if he was acting under
any particular orders from general aries
no general
he replied with an air of relief i've
lost aries i have no orders i don't know
what to do
then you come with me i said i will take
responsibility
you shall have all the credit
let me take your brigade for a moment so
that's in two pages you've got giving
ownership
and taking ownership
in two pages in two paragraphs really
and by the way i'll take responsibility
you'll have all the credit
this dude is like deal
deal and deal
uh
then
sheridan was by my side in a moment very
angry you are firing into my cavalry
here we get blue on blue
he exclaims his face darkening with a
checked expletive
i was under a little pressure too and
put on a bold air
then the cavalry have got gotten into
the rebels place one of us will have to
get out of the way what will you have us
do general
don't you fire into my cavalry i'll tell
you
was the fierce rejoiner so
we got this freaking mayhem going on
fast forward a little bit more they kind
of sort that out i plunged into my
business to make up for a minute's lost
time my men were
still facing too much across aries front
and getting into the range of his fire
we had got
we had got to change that and swing to
the right down the rear of the enemy's
main works it was a whirl every way was
a front and every way was a flank the
fighting was hand to hand i was trying
to get the three angles of the triangle
into something like two right angles and
it swung my left well forward opening
quite a gap in that direction when a
large body of the enemy came rushing in
from that flank and rear
they were in line formation with arms at
something like a ready which looked like
business
i thought it was our turn to be caught
between two fires and that these men
were likely to cut their way through us
rushing into the ranks of my left
battalion i shouted the order prepared a
fire by the rear rank
my men faced about at once disregarding
the enemy in the front
but at this juncture our portness
visitors threw down their muskets and
with hands and faces cried out we
surrender
running right up upon and almost over us
i was very glad of it though more
astonished for they outnumbered us
largely
that's the kind of turn of events that
you like
and it's it it's one of those things
that reminds me
that
he could have surrendered right there he
could have surrendered hey you know what
we're surrounded hey everyone drop your
weapons
it's that it's going that extra little
moment
right that extra you know what happens
in fighting in boxing and mma fighting
where that extra like i'll go one more
round who was it was uh
was that ali
frazier
and
ali had returned to his corner saying
take off my take off my gloves like i'm
done
and they you know they're basically no
you're not done he's like no i'm done
and they said no you're not done so he's
okay and
i think it was frasier said he was done
didn't answer the bell so he won
but it was just that
he could have easily surrendered but he
didn't knife it held on for a little bit
longer so hickson do that too like that
was kind of his do you remember when he
when he was young against zulu what
happened where he he just felt like no
i'm kind of done and they're like no no
no oh yeah that's right
for sure he got to the after the first
round
they bring hicks in the side and they're
like hey hickson says i'm done man i'm
done
like i can't this isn't gonna work i'm
done i'm physically exhausted and they
say no you're not done yet son
but the other guy was yeah
um
[Music]
this battle continues the hardest hold
up was in front of my left center the
first battalion of the 198th
pennsylvania i wrote up to the gallant
glenn commanding it and said major glenn
if you will break that line you shall
have a colonel's commission
it was a hasty utterance
and the promise on military perhaps but
my every energy was focused on that
moment's issue nor did that earnest
soldier need a personal inducement he
was already carrying out the general
order to press the enemy before him with
as much effect as we could reasonably
expect
but it was deep in my mind how richly he
already deserved this promotion and i
was resolved that he should get it now
it was this thought and purpose which no
doubt shaped my phrase and pardoned it
glenn sprung among his men calling out
boys
will you follow me
wheeled his horse and dashed forward
without turning to see who followed nor
did he need
his words were a question
his act
in order
yeah
he doesn't say doesn't give an order he
literally asks the question
will you follow me and then goes
leadership by example
and whatever kind of relationship and
respect he had from his troops
that when they see him go
they go
his words were questioned his acting
order
on the brave fellows go with a cheer
into the hurricane of fire their
beautiful flag sways grateful gracefully
aloft with the spring of brave youth
bearing it lighting the battle smoke
three times it goes down to earth
covered in darkening eddies but rises
ever again passing from hand to hand of
dauntless young heroes
then
bullet torn and blood blazoned it hovers
for a moment above the breastwork while
the regiment goes over like a wave
this i saw from my position to the left
where i was pressing on the rest of my
command
the sight wrought upon me that i
snatched time to ride over and
congratulate glenn and his regiment
as i passed into a deeper shadow of the
woods
i met two men burying his body
the dripping blood marking their path
they stopped to tell me
i saw it all too well
he had snatched a battle flag from a
broken regiment trying to rally on its
colors when a brute bullet of the earth
once pronounced good but since cursed
for man's sin
struck him down to its level
i could not stop i could stop but for a
moment
for still on my front was rush and
turmoil and tragedy i could only bend
down over him from the saddle and murmur
unavailing words
general
i have carried out your wishes
this was his only utterance
was as if
another bullet had cut through me
i fell almost across my saddle
my wish
god in heaven no more my wish than thine
that this fair body still part of the
unfallen good should be smitten to the
sod
that this spirit born of thine should be
quenched by the accursed
what dark misgivings searched me as i
took the import of these words what
sharp sense of responsibility for those
who have committed to them the issues of
life and death why should i have not let
this onset take its general course and
mend their natural chances why choose
him out for his death and so take on
myself the awful decision into what home
irreparable loss and measureless
desolation should cast their unlifted
burden
the crowding fought choked utterance
i could only bend my face low
to his and answer
colonel
i will remember my promise
i will remember you
and press forward to my place where the
crash and crush and agony of the
struggle summoned me more
to more of the same
war
nothing but the final infinite good for
man and god can accept
and justify human work like that
yeah this um
that
massive burden that he feels just
absolutely hitting him
yeah again there's
not much for me to say on that
and even with that the battle's not over
go forward a little bit and we had now
come to the edge of a wide field across
the road and the works on the enemy's
right known as the gillum field
here i came to sheridan and griffin my
troops all up and well in hand a sharp
cavalry fight was going on in which some
of ares men and my own had taken part
when our line was checked at the last
angle griffin had ordered one of
crawford's kernels to advance
the colonel a brave well-balanced man
replied that
where soldiers as good as griffin's men
had failed
he did not feel warranted in going in
without proper orders
very well i order you in says griffin
without adding that he did it as
commander of the corps
so there's a
colonel sitting there
and
there's this battle going on
and griffin says hey you need to get in
there
and the colonel says well
hey i don't think i should go in there
if these guys can't get it done i don't
think i should go in there unless i'm
under orders and griffin says very well
then i order you in
so he gives a little push back hey this
doesn't seem like a great call and then
he gets told you're going in
the gallant colonel bows
it is richardson of the 7th wisconsin
grasps his regimental colors in his own
hand significant of the need of his
resolution and face of it and rides
forward in advance of his men
what can they do but follow such example
general warren
with intensity of feeling that is now
desperation snatches his core flag from
the hands of its bearer and dashes up to
richardson's side
and so
the two leaders ride the core commander
and his last visible kernel colors aloft
reckless of the growing distance between
them and their followers straight for
the smoking line straight for the
flaming edge not hesitating at the
breast works over they go
one with swelling toll molt of soul
where the passion of suffering craves
outburst in action the other with
obedience and self-devotion love-like
stronger than death
over the breast works down among the
astonished foe one of whom instinct over
mastering admiration aims at the
foremost a deadly blow
which the noble youth rushes forward to
perry and shielding with his own breast
of his certain of his uncaring commander
falls to earth bathing his colors with
his blood
need more be told
do men terry at such a point
one crested wave sweeps on another
broken rolls away all is lost
and all is one
slowly warren returns over the sombra
field
so
that's just an unbelievable scene
you know it's just an unbelievable scene
if you tried to make that in a movie it
wouldn't seem realistic
that
this guy richardson gets told hey you
need to charge he says i don't think i
should do that without proper orders
his boss says these are your orders go
and as he takes off towards the melee
the overall leader
without saying a word just grabs his
flag and joins him by his side
once they get to the enemy lines
somebody takes aim it
at
warren
and richardson basically jumps in front
of he says blow i don't know if it's a
shot or if it was a sword or what it was
but i'm assuming he was shot
and richardson takes the round
i'm i mean you consider like an enemy
breast works and they're coming over it
in their horses and then once they come
over they got to be in and amongst them
so it could have been
either it could have been a sword i
guess
bayonet bayonet yeah
[Music]
and then this happens as it is forsaken
at its forsaken edge a staff officer
hands him this is warren this is so
warren walks back after this or rides
back after this
and a staff officer hands him a crude
field order
partly by the lurid
flashes of the last guns partly by the
light of the dying day
he reads quote major general warren
commandee commanding the fifth army
corps is relieved from duty and will at
once report for orders to lieutenant
general general grant commanding arms
the united states
by command of major general sheridan end
quote
so he just got fired
with almost the agony of death upon his
face warren approaches sheridan and asks
him if he cannot reconsider the order
reconsider hell i don't reconsider my
decisions obey the order
that was the last thunderbolt on
warren's heart
the battle has done its worst for him
the iron has entered his soul
so
all that kind of mayhem and
disorganization and all those different
orders and stuff
um
caused eventually him to get fired
and
there's some details in the book about
him moving too slow him not being at the
front
so
fast forward a little bit suddenly
emerged from the shadows
a compact form with vigorous stride
unlike the measure and mood of ours and
a voice that would itself have thrilled
us had it not
had not the import of it thrilled us
more gentlemen says sheridan
as we have started to our feet i've come
to see you
i may have spoken harshly to some of you
today but i would not have it hurt you
you know how it is we had to carry this
place and i was fretted all day till it
was done you must forgive me
i know it is hard for the men too
but we must push
there's more for us to do together
i appreciate and thank you all
and this is phil sheridan
a new view of him surely and amazingly
all the repressed feeling of our hearts
sprung out toward him we were ready to
blame ourselves if we had been in any
way the cause of his trouble
but we thought
we had borne a better part than that
so this guy sheridan who's been barking
orders and stuff all day now rolls in
after he fires warren
and says hey guys look i i know i was
hard today um
but
i'm sorry i was wrong you know you must
forgive me he's asking for forgiveness
and
i mean it landed
apparently really well
you know
because reading this it's it's really
apparent that
chamberlain is sympathetic to one
and ain't all that thrilled with
sheridan um and then you know you see
his response there when sheridan
was smart yeah takes ownership and he's
taking the situation ownership of it and
re regaining some leadership capital
because
apologizing requires you to do a huge
checking your ego
and yeah i can't think of a situation
where you anyone loses respect for you
when you apologize
yeah
yeah this is a a good case of that um
yeah we just went through that whole
thing with uh
with wrote with joe rogan
and
you know him apologizing and there was a
bunch of people and i i just basically
tried to lend support to him and saying
that
hey let's the guys apologized
forgiveness is
a virtue that we should all
try and
go after and try and represent and so
when somebody makes a mistake
you know that's what forgiveness is for
and
uh a bunch of people not a bunch of
people but some people were saying you
should never apologize no it's never i
hear that too with leaders leaders say
oh it's weak to apologize man if you
mess something up
then apologize
and and hey in in a minimum if i say
something to you that maybe
maybe i i offended you
well what did i want to offend you and
if i didn't maybe if maybe if it's uh
you know i say well geez jason you know
you're you and your stupid freaking
blonde hair right
you know and all of a sudden i realized
that you know you used to get picked on
for that
and even though i meant it as a joke but
it offended you
does that mean we'll hey i didn't know i
didn't know that you used to get picked
on because of that i'm not apologizing
no it's actually hey man i'm sorry
the way i said it and the thing that i
didn't know was gonna offend you
offended you and i'm sorry about that
like there's nothing wrong when you make
a mistake of saying sorry
nothing wrong what i really appreciated
about
rogan's apology is that he wasn't
sidestepping any consequences yeah well
you know just because you say you're
sorry doesn't mean there are no
consequences hey it's all good i
apologize no but he
he took ownership of what happened he
wasn't trying to weasel out of any
consequences and i thought
that it was a huge lesson on how what
the right thing to do is
when something comes out and i i
actually gained quite a bit of respect i
had a fair amount of respect for joe
before that but but
his apology was was heartfelt and
sincere and and wasn't an attempt to
avoid consequences yeah which is awesome
and when you make a mistake as a leader
when you pick the wrong plan when i say
hey jason i want you to you know can you
prep this
freaking brief from me
and then
it turns out we don't need to do the
brief and i'm like hey man i know you
worked for two weeks on that thing and
we didn't
need to even do it
i'm sorry man as opposed to saying well
you know we could have used it or
whatever just making up the big cover-up
the big lie yeah you know and just like
hey man i'm so sorry i know i went you
wasted two weeks working on that working
on that brief and we ended up not using
it i should have done a better
i should have done more ground work to
make sure we're going to need it and i'm
sorry your respect for me doesn't go
down it goes up you know it's like i i
was wrong
and when i when i was when as i'm
reading this and i'm and i i'm like oh
god here comes sharon again he's going
to yell at him
and then
i'm like oh look at him go he's
apologizing and then he writes about
like hey we were all as soon as he did
that he completely flipped yeah their
feelings towards him yep a new view of
him surely and amazingly
if that's such a great case for taking
ownership and apologizing when you screw
something up
um
he's talking a little bit about about
about the the
the personalities and the attitudes and
one thing he's talking about sheridan
so this is sort of a detached moment he
says sheridan does not entrench he
pushes on carrying his flank and rear
with him rushing flashing smashing
he transfuses into his subordinates the
vitality and energy of his purpose
transforms them into part of his own
mind and will he shows the power of a
commander inspiring both confidence and
fear
as a rule our core and army commanders
were men of brains rather than magnetism
they relied on brains in others warren
was one of these
he was well capable of organizing an
entire plan of battle on a great field
he would have been an admirable chief of
staff of the army so he's again again
this is the personality of warren warren
was like not a dynamic
charismatic individual he was good at
planning
their brains outweigh temperament so
when you're coming up with a plan
your brains are more important
he could see the whole comprehensively
and adjust the parts to subordinate it
but he had a certain order of
temperament which although it brought
him distinction as a subordinate
commander
seemed to work against him as a core
commander yeah this is
man you got it you gotta
you gotta adjust look
well we'll get into it well we'll just
do it now you look if you are the
the second in command if you're the
chief operating option you got to make
things happen
and you're the one that goes hey jason
you need to get this [__] done right now
and you're like yeah got it boss
and then i elevate to being the ceo
i need to change my
behavior and i need to be the
be the
the bigger personality the the more
positive personality
that's what i need to do
the the more charismatic the more
dynamic i don't want to be the one in
the weeds
when i'm overall in charge
now if i have the personality where like
hey i'm a great at coming up with the
plans and this is the way we're going to
do this that's cool but when i promote
above that and now i've gotta show the
vision you gotta you gotta
adjust you gotta grow and you gotta
mature
and by the way sometimes you go back
down to that position because you could
be leading a department where you gotta
be kind of charismatic and and then you
get promoted to ceo now you got to be
like a little bit more of the the
planner and a little bit more mechanical
and then you get promoter ceo and now
you got to be back to the dynamic
individual again
so
so part of the reason i want to say that
is because yes you have a personality we
all have a personality
but
you don't necessarily you know have to
behave the same way and like i when i
was an assistant platoon commander
you know i had to subdue some of my
enthusiasm about things when i i i was
more into the detailed planning hey i
got that paperwork let me run that when
i was a platoon commander all of a
sudden i stepped up into the more
dynamic role got out of the details
and that's what you're gonna have to do
throughout your career
and you have to pay attention to what
your personality sort of lends itself to
um there was guys that i worked for that
were executive officers the number two
in command at a seal team and they were
great executive officers
as commanding officers maybe not so
great
there was people that were great
commanding officers as executive
officers maybe not so great
they just have a personality
but at least you should you should know
where your personality is and then
modulate
your personality to the job that you're
in
yeah and the only way you're going to do
that is to detach yeah
that's the only way otherwise you're
just swept away by your personality yeah
and i so that you know in the navy every
two years you're promoting
and right about the time you figure out
how to do that job
you get up to the next job and then
you're doing the next job like that last
job for a little while
until you figure things out
hopefully you figure it out like it
didn't it didn't just work out for
warren there's there's a whole bunch of
circumstances where things didn't work
out for warren and maybe in other
circumstances would have been fine but
it didn't sound like he was
the dynamic leader and that's
that is a hard thing to do because
you're going to start out doing what you
know and unless you're willing to take
feedback
and so
you know the 360 feedback is something
that we started doing
in in the teams and so you get feedback
from your subordinates and that's
painful to hear to look at that stuff
sometimes you're like oh
but it's so liberating because you're
like oh okay
and you can tell when you read the
feedback on who's and kissing ass and
who's just angry about everything and
they're just going to be angry about it
who's giving you honest feedback it's
like oh i got to stop doing that or
adjust that or i'm stepping on that
guy's toes
and pull it back
um
still still here talking about warren he
said it led him to go in
personally with a single division or
brigade when a sharp fight came on doing
this when he when having a larger
command one takes a risk of losing grasp
of the hole so he's going into that like
hey i'm used to doing this job down in
the weeds i'm going to get down the
weeds
that was what he did trying to change
the front with crawford's division under
fire it was a difficult thing he put his
personality into it which is what you
just said jason just as sheridan would
do
and did in this very fight
um
there's a whole section that covers some
of that criticism about warren and his
subordinates um any and
and uh chamberlain goes on to say these
accusations against the conduct of
each of warren's divisions while
susceptible of being magnified and
manipulated so as to produce a certain
forensic effect
are of no substantial weight
even if true in the sharpest sense so
even if warren's subordinates were
totally jacked up look he's saying look
you can create you can look in the back
and say like oh these guys were bad this
guy did this wrong this guy did that
wrong and you can produce a certain
forensic effect
but even if that's true in the sharpest
sense
they would be over strained and uncalled
for considering how the battle ended and
by whom it was mainly fought
in a military and highly proper sense
general warren was responsible for the
conduct of his core and ultimately for
that of each of his divisions
there you have it
you got
people that work for you you got
departments under you got divisions
underneath you you got platoons or
battalions or companies underneath you
you are responsible for what all those
people do
there are two ways in which such control
might be exercised by prevention or by
correction so i'm either going to say
jason you know what you're not doing
this job well you're not doing this job
you're fired or hey jason you're not
doing this job well here's the
corrections you need to make that's what
you do
for hey jason i know that you're going
to set everything on fire
don't set everything on fire which is
correction right yeah which is
preventable i guess that's perfect
preemptive that's prevention
prevention
um it was crawford's duty to keep his
vital connection with ares and if in any
way should be broken to be on the alert
to see an act warren should hold him
should hold him responsible for that and
if he knew he could not at the start
rouse cro crawford whose peculiarities
he knew to a vivid conception of the
anatomy and physiology of the case he
should have had a staff officer charged
with the duty of keeping crawford closed
on aries while he himself at the point
where he could keep in touch with his
whole core and hold griffin under his
hand at the ready
and trusted reserve prepared for the
unexpected so he's saying the same thing
you and i just said like if if if echo's
a little bit of a wild man and i'm not
quite sure who's going to do cool i'd
take jason my trusted guy and say hey
man go with echo
let me know what he's doing he gets a
little wild sometimes
you and dave call that preemptive
ownership preemptive ownership
good deal dave good deal dave there you
go cover down
i gotta pick up the slack
and now we get to appomattix appomattox
fast forward a little bit i'm about to
speak of what came under my observation
in the action at appomattox appomattox
courthouse and the circumstances
attending the surrender of the army of
northern virginia april 9th 1865.
so now they're
20 25 miles or so from five forks the
battle that they were just in
this is
a week later eight days later something
like that
they had to march that that time
um he says the fifth corps had a very
hard march that day made more so in the
afternoon and night by the lumbering
obstructions of the rear of ord's tired
column by courtesy given the road before
us the incessant check fretting our men
almost a mutiny
we had been rushed all day to keep up
with the cavalry
but this constant checking was worse
we did not know that grant had set
orders to the fifth quarter march all
night without halting but it was not
necessary for us to know it after 29
miles of this kind of marching at the
blackest hour of night human nature had
called a halt
dropping by the roadside left and right
wet or dry downwind men as in a soon
swoon
officers slid out of the saddle loosened
the girth slipped an arm through the
loop of a bridal rain and sunk to sleep
horses stood with drooping heads just
above their masters faces all dreaming
one knows not of what of past
or coming
possible or faded
scarcely is the first broken dream begun
when a cavalry man comes splashing down
the road and vigorously dismounts
pulling from his jacket a crumpled note
the sentinel standing watched by his
commander warren and body but alert in
every sense touches your shoulder orders
sir i think
you rise on your elbow strike a match
and with smarting streaming eyes read
the brief
thrilling note from sheridan like this
as i remember quote i have cut across
the enemy at appomattox
station
and captured three of his trains if you
can possibly push your infantry
up here tonight we will have great
results in the morning
end quote
ah
no more sleep
the startling bugle notes the ring out
to the march word is sent for the men to
take a bite of such as they had for food
the promised rations would not be up
till noon and by that time we should be
where
they don't even know
they are there men shivering to their
senses as if written out of risen out of
the earth but something in them not of
it
now sounds the forward for the last time
in our long drawn strife and they move
these men sleepless supperless
breakfastless sore-footed stiff-jointed
sense-be-numbed
but with flushed faces pressing for the
front
some hard men
freaking hard
uh they march
eventually they arrive on station i ride
straight to sheridan a dark smile an
impetuous gesture are my only orders
forward
into double lines of battle past
sheridan his guns as cavalry and on for
the quivering crest
for a moment it is a glorious sight
every arm of the service in full play
cavalry
artillery infantry then a sudden shift
shifting scene as the cavalry disengaged
by successive squadrons rally under
their bugle calls with beautiful
precision and promptitude and sweep like
a storm cloud beyond our right to close
in on the enemies left and complete the
fateful envelopment
we take up battle gregory follows in on
my left it is a formidable way front we
make the scene darkens in a few minutes
the tide is turned the incoming wave is
at high flood the barrier recedes in
truth the stonewall men hardly show
their well-proved metal they seem
astonished to see before them familiar
flags of their old antagonists not
having thought it possible that we could
match our cavalry and march around and
across their pressing columns
and i don't think i did a good job of
laying out the way that went but these
soldiers had marched to keep up with the
cavalry and had gotten there in 29 miles
in a very short period of time
their last hope is gone to break through
our cavalry before our infantry can get
up
neither to danville nor to lynchburg can
they cut their way and close upon their
rear five miles away are pressing the
second and sixth core of the army of the
potomac
it is the end they are now giving way
but keep up good front by force of old
habit
halfway up the slope they make a stand
with what perhaps they think a good omen
behind a stone wall
i try a little artillery on them which
directs their thoughts towards the crest
behind them and stiffens my lines for a
rush
anxious for that crust myself crest
myself
but now comes up ored with a positive
order don't expose your lines on that
crest the enemy have massed their guns
to hat to give it a raking fire the
moment you set foot there
i thought i saw a qualifying look as he
turned away but left alone youth
struggled with prudence my troops were
in a bad position down here i did not
like to be
the duh the underdog it was much better
to be on top and at least know what was
there beyond
so i thought of grant and his permission
to quote push things
when we got them going and of sheridan
and his last words as he rode away with
his cavalry smiting his hands together
quote now smash them i tell you smash
them end quote
so we took this for orders
and on the crest we stood
one booming cannon shot passed close
along our front and in the next moment
all was still
so
he gets told
don't go up to that crest
but he's in a bad situation anyways and
he thinks hey i'm gonna i'm this isn't
good
what are some other orders i've received
recently well i've also got told to push
things i've also got told to smash them
so i'm going to take some initiative
here and we're going we're going to get
to that crest
and when he gets up there turns out
there's just one cannon shot
we had done it
had exposed ourselves to the view of the
enemy but it was an exposure that worked
two ways for their burst upon our vision
a mighty scene fit cadence the story of
tumultuous years encompassed by the
cordon of steel that crowned the heights
about the courthouse on the slopes of
the valley formed by the sources of the
appomattox
lay the remnants of that far famed army
counterpart and companion of our own in
momentous history
the army of northern virginia lee's army
and so now he's standing up in this
position looking down
and can see the entire scene from his
elevated position
and including the appomattox
appomattox
sorry
around and here's what he describes
around its edges now trodden to mire
swarms an indescribable crowd
worn out soldiers struggling to the
front demoralized citizen and denizen
white black and all shades between
following lee's army or flying before
these suddenly confronted terrible
yankees pictured to them as demon shape
and bent
animals too of all forms and grades
vehicles of every description and
non-description public and domestic
four-wheeled or two or one heading and
moving in every direction a swarming
mass of chaotic confusion
so with a fervor of devout joy as when
perhaps the old crusaders first caught
sight of the holy city of their quest
with an uproaring of heart that was half
pagan half prayer we dash forward to the
consummation
a solitary field piece in the edge of
town gives an angry but expiring
defiance we press down the little slope
through a little swamp over a bright
swift stream our advances already in the
town
only the narrow street between the
opposing lines and hardly that
there is wild work that looks
frightening
but not much killing nor even hurting
the disheartened enemy take it easy
our men take them easier
it is a wild mild fusing earnest
but not deadly earnest
a young orderly of mine unable to
contain himself begs permission to go
forward and dashes in sword flourishing
as if he was a terrible fellow
his demonstrations seemingly more
amusing than resisted for he soon comes
back hugging four sabres to his breast
speechless at his achievement
new guy going in
so you can see the the confederate army
is kind of falling apart
and these guys are
charging in expecting a fight and
there's just not that much of a fight
and then this
suddenly rose to our site another form
close in our own front a soldierly young
figure handsomely dressed and mounted
a confederate staff officer undoubtedly
to whom some of my advanced line seemed
to be pointing my position
now i see the white flag earnestly born
and it's possible
purport sweeps before my inner vision
like a wraith of mourning mist
he comes steadily on the mysterious
forming gray my mood so whimsical
sensitive that i could even smile at the
material of the flag wondering where in
either army was found a towel and one so
white
but it bore a mighty message
that simple emblem of homely service
wafted hitherward above the dark and
crimsoned streams that never can wash
themselves away
the messenger draws near dismounts with
graceful salutation and hardly
suppressed emotion delivers his message
sir
i am from general gordon general lee
desires a cessation of hostilities until
he can hear from general grant as to the
proposal of surrender
what word is this
so long so dearly fought for so
feverishly dreamed but never but ever
snatched away held hidden and aloof now
smiting the senses with dizzy flash
surrender we had no rumor of this from
the long messages that had been passing
between grant lee for now these two days
between behind us surrender
it takes a moment to gather one's speech
sir i answer that matter exceeds my
authority
i will send to my superior general lee
is right
he can do no more
all this with a forced calmness covering
a tumult of heart and brain
i bid him wait a while and the message
goes up to my core commander general
griffin leaving me
amazed at the boating change
even here he's trying to remain calm
like purposely forced calmness
now from the right come foaming up in
cavalry fashion two forms i'd watched
from a way beyond a white flag again
held strong aloft making straight for
the little group beneath our battle flag
highborn also the red maltese cross on a
white field that had thrilled hearts
long ago
i see now that is one of our cavalry
staff in the lead
indeed i recognize him colonel whitaker
of custer's staff and hardly keeping
pace with him a confederate staff
officer
without dismounting without salutation
the cavalry man shouts
this is unconditional surrender this is
the end
then he hastily introduces his companion
and adds
i am just from gordon and long street
gordon says for god's sake stop this
infantry or
hell will be to pay
i'll go to sheridan
he adds and dashes away with a white
flag leaving long street's aid with me
the captains cry holt the rebels want to
surrender the more men want to be there
and see it still to the front where the
real fun is
and the forward takes an upward turn
for when we do succeed in stopping their
advance we cannot keep their arms and
legs from flying to the top of fences
and haystacks and chimneys they clamber
to toss their old caps higher in the air
and leave the earth as far below as they
can dear old general gregory gallops up
to inquire the meaning of this strange
departure from a custom discipline
only that lee wants time to surrender i
answer glory to god
roars the grave and brave old general
your legs have done it my men he shouts
galloping up cap in hand generously
forgiving our disobedience of orders and
rash exposure on the dubious crest
true enough their legs had done it had
matched the cavalry as grant admitted
had cut around lee's best doings and
commanded the grand halt
but other things had done it
the blood was still fresh upon the
quaker road the white oak ridge five
forks farmville high bridge and sailors
creek
and we take somewhat gravely this
compliment of our new commander of the
army of the james
at last after pardoning something to the
spirit of liberty
we get things quiet along the lines
one o'clock comes
no answer from lee
nothing for us but to shake hands and
take arms to resume hostilities as i
turned to go general griffin said to me
in a low voice prepare to make or
receive an attack in ten minutes
it was a sudden change in tone in our
relations and brought a queer sensation
where my troops had halted the opposing
lines were in close proximity the men
stacked arms the men had stacked arms
and were resting in place
it did not seem like war we were going
to recommence but willful murder
but the order was only to prepare and
that we did
our troops were in good position my
advanced line across the road and we
stood fast intensely waiting
i had mounted and sat looking at the
scene before me thinking of all that was
impending and depending
when i felt it
coming upon
a strange sense of some presence
invisible but powerful like those
unearthly visitants told of an ancient
story charged with supernatural message
disquieted i turned about
and there behind me
riding in between my two lines appeared
a commanding form superbly mounted
richly accr accoutred
of imposing bearing noble countenance
with expression of deep sadness over
mastered by deeper strength
it is no other than robert e lee
and seen by me for the first time within
my own lines i sat immovable with a
certain awe and admiration
he was coming with a single staff
officer
for the great appointed meeting which
was to determine
momentous issues
not long after
but another in leading road appeared
another form plain unassuming simple and
familiar to our eyes but but to the
thought as much inspiring as lee
in his splendor and his sadness it is
grant
[Music]
he too comes with a single aide a staff
officer of sheridan's
slouched hat without cord common soldier
blouse unbuttoned on which however the
four stars high boots mud splashed to
the top trousers tucked inside no sword
but the sword hand deep in the pocket
sitting his saddle with the ease of a
born master taking no notice of anything
at all all his faculties gathered into
intense thought and mighty calm he
seemed greater than i'd ever seen him a
look of another world about him
no wonder i forgot all together to
salute him anything like that would have
been too little too little
staff officers are flying
crying lee surrenders
ah there was some kind of strength left
among those worn and famished men
belting the hills around the springs of
appomattox
who rent the air with shouting and
uproar as if the earth and sea had
joined the song our men did
what they thought their share
and then went to sleep as they had as
they had need to do
but in the opposite camp they acted as
if they got a hold of something too good
to keep and gave it to the stars
besides they had supper that night which
was something of a novelty
for we had divided rations with our old
antagonists now
they were by our side as suffering
brothers
so they're they're well
in truth long street
had come over to our camp that evening
with an unwanted moisture on his
marshall cheek and compressed words on
his lips
gentlemen i must speak plainly
we are starving over there for god's
sake can you send us something we were
men
and we acted like men knowing we should
suffer it for ourselves we were too
short rationed also and had been for
days but must
be for days to come
we sent over to that starving camp
share and share alike for all there with
ourselves
again that's like amazing to
the uh sort of mutual respect almost
instantly to try and help out these
your enemy
how about long streets coming over by
he's not sending a staff officer or
anybody else he's going yeah to say hey
bring my guy some food
so there's some forgiveness
this was also interesting late that
night i was summoned to headquarters
where general griffin informed me that i
was to command the parade on the
occasion of the formal surrender of the
arms and colors of lee's army
he said the confederates had begged hard
to be allowed to stack their arms on the
ground where they were
and let us go pick them up after they
had gone
so that was their plan the confederates
said hey let us just leave our weapons
and we're going to bail
but grant did not think this quite
respectful enough to anybody including
the united states of america and while
he would have all private property
respected and would permit officers to
retain their sidearms he insisted that
surrender
that the surrendering army as such
should march out and do order and lay
down all tokens of confederate authority
and organized hostility to the united
states in an immediate presence of some
representative portion of the union army
griffin added in a significant tone that
grant wished the ceremony to be as
simple as possible and that nothing
should be done to humiliate the manhood
of the southern soldiers
so there's like a little balance there
like hey
we'll share some food with you but you
got to come and
you got to come and surrender proper
it was now the morning of the 12th of
april
i had been ordered to have my lines
formed for the ceremony at sunrise it
was a chill gray morning depressing to
the senses we formed along the principal
street
we were the remnants also
massachusetts maine maryland michigan
pennsylvania new york
veterans and replaced veterans
cut to pieces cut down consolidated
divisions into brigades regiments into
one gathered by state origin back to
their place of birth
this little line
quint quintessence
a metapsychosis of porter's old core of
gains mill of maverick hill
men of near bloodborne made nearer by
bloodshed
those facing us
now thank god the same
our earnest eyes can scan the busy
groups on the opposite slopes breaking
camp for the last time
taking down the little shelter tents and
folding them carefully as precious
things than slowly forming ranks as for
unwelcome duty
and now they move the dusky swarms
forged forward into gray columns of
march on they come with the old swinging
root step
and swaying battle flags
instructions had been given
and when the head of each division
column comes opposite our camp our bugle
sounds the signal and instantly our
whole line from right to left regiment
by regiment in succession gives the
soldiers salutation from the order arms
to the old carry
the marching salute
gordon at the head of the column riding
with heavy spirit and down cast face
catches the sound of shifting arms looks
up and taking the meaning wheels
superbly making himself and his horse
one uplifted figure with the pro
profound salutation as he drops the
point of his sword to the boot toe then
facing to his own command gives word for
successive brigades to pass us with the
same position of manual
honor answering for honor
our part
on our part not a sound of trumpet
nor roll of drum
not a cheer nor word of whisper of vain
glory nor motion of a man standing again
at the order but an odd stillness rather
and breath-holding
as if it were the passing of the dead
they fix bayonets
stack arms then hesitantly remove
cartridge boxes and lay them down
lastly
reluctantly with agony of expression
they tenderly fold their flags battle
worn and torn blood-stained
heart-holding colors
and lay them down
some friendly rushing from the ranks
kneeling over them clinging to them
pressing them to their lips with burning
tears
and only the flag of the union greets
the sky
what visions thronged as we looked into
each other's eyes here past the men of
antietam the bloody lane the sunken road
the cornfield the burnside bridge the
men whom stonewalled jackson on the
second night at fredericksburg begged
lee to let him take and crush the two
core of the army of the potomac huddled
in the streets in the darkness and
confusion the men who swept the 11th
corps at chancellorville who left 6 000
of their companions around the bases of
culps and cemetery hills at gettysburg
these survivors of the terrible
wilderness the bloody angle at
spotsylvania the slaughter pen of cold
harbor the whirlpool of bethesda church
here comes cobb's georgia legion
which held the stone wall on mary's
heights at fredericksburg
closed before which we piled our dead
for breast work
so that the living might stay alive
here too come gordon's georgians and
hoax north carolinians who stood before
the terrific mine explosion at
petersburg
and advancing retook the smoking crater
and the dismal heaps of dead ours more
than theirs huddled in the ghastly chasm
here are the men of mcgowan's hunting
and scales who broke the fifth coral
lines on the white oak road and were so
desperately driven back on that forlorn
night of march the 31st by thrice
decimated brigade
now comes anderson's fourth corps
only bushrod and bushrod johnson's
division left
and this the remnant
of those we fought so fiercely on quaker
road two weeks ago with wise's legion
too fierce for its own good
here passes the proud remnant of ramses
north ransoms north carolinians
who were swept through five forks ten
days ago and all
the little that was left of this
division in the sharp passages at
sailors creek five days thereafter
now makes its last front
ap hills old core
hath now at the lead since hill had gone
too far forward ever to return
the men who poured destruction into our
division at shepherdstown ford antietam
in 62 when hill reported the potomac the
potomac running blue with our bodies
the men who opened the desperate first
days fight at gettysburg where
withstanding them so stubbornly our
robinson's brigade lost
1185 men and the iron brigade alone
1153 these men of heth's division here
too losing 2 850 men
companions of these now looking into our
faces so differently
now the sad great pageant long street
and his men
what shall we give them for greeting
that has not already been spoken in
volleys of thunder and written in lines
of fire all over the banks of virginia
shall we go back to gaines mill or
malvern hill
or to antietam
or of maryland or gettysburg of
pennsylvania
deepest graven of all for here is what
remains of kershaw's division
which left 40 percent of its men at
antietam and at gettysburg with
barksdale and sam's brigade tore through
the peach orchard
rolling up our rolling up the right of
our gallant third core sweeping over the
proud batteries of massachusetts bigelow
and phillips where under the smoke we
saw earth brown and blue with prostrated
bodies of men and horses and the tongues
of overturned cannon
pointing grim and stark in the air
then in the wilderness and at
spotsylvania kershaw again in deeds of
awful glory and thereafter
for all their losses holding their name
and fame until feet fate met them at
sailors creek where all but these
with kershaw himself and
yule
and so many more gave up their arms and
hopes
all indeed
but manhood's honor
with what strange emotion i looked into
these faces before which in the mad
assault river
on reeves salient june 18 64 i was left
for dead under their eyes
it is by miracles we have lived to see
this day any of us standing here
now comes the sinewy remnant of
fierce hoods division which at
gettysburg we saw pouring through the
devil's den and plum run gorge turning
again by the left our stubborn third
core then swarming up the rocky bastions
of round top to be met there by equal
valor which changed lee's whole plan of
battle and perhaps the story of
gettysburg
ah is this pickett's division
this little group left of those who on
the lurid last day of gettysburg
breasted level crossfire and
thunderbolts of storm to be strewn back
drifting wrecks where after that awful
futile pitiful charge we buried them in
graves a furlong wide with names unknown
man again in the terrible cyclone sweep
over the breast works at five forks met
now so thin so pale purged of the mortal
as if knowing pain or joy no more
how could we help falling on our knees
all of us together and praying god to
pity
and forgive us all
so
you know i don't know if you can capture
the emotions that these guys must have
felt on both sides at this juncture but
i that must be a pretty close proximity
to at least
the best you could do to capture those
emotions
um
and there's another
the the book goes on
uh and there's a powerful section
where
he because that that section there you
know he kind of calls out name by name
the various units and there's a section
where there's a parade
for the army of the potomac and it's
incredible pop incredibly powerful as
well
and he goes by unit by unit um
there's one point where he brings up the
fact that while warren was
warned there was a there was basically a
trial
because warren said hey i shouldn't have
been fired he wanted to kind of redeem
himself
and there's he brings up a point where
someone was asking one of the one of the
cross-examining lawyers asked warren hey
when you're in this battle where where
were your regulars
and warren looks at him with a bold and
quivering lip
and says buried sir at gettysburg
and
yeah that's
it's it's hard to do this book justice
um
without just reading the entire thing
and there's just stories upon stories
in in this book
and
lessons so many lessons that we we
barely touched into
like i said before if you get a chance
to go to gettysburg go there
go there
uh we go there if you want to come there
with us go check that out but
there's one more section um
that i wanted to cover in the book
um
joshua chamberlain is
he's he's with some of his surviving
troops
um in maine
and there'd been some kind of scrambling
of of the organization the 20th may to
become combined with the 16th and the
second
and the war's finished
and i tried to figure out how long after
the war this was i'm not i couldn't
couldn't quite identify when exactly
this was but
they're at a banquet
and chamberlain
you know this whole both these podcasts
we were talking about the flags and the
meaning of these colors right what they
meant what they represented
and during the defense of little round
top at some point they had lost their
colors
at some point you know during this
freaking mayhem
they lost their colors
and
it you know this is a symbolic event
like i said like you were saying it's a
tactical event there there's actually a
tactical reason for those colors but
it's also symbolic as well
and
at some point these
during the battle of gettysburg and i'm
not exactly sure when it was i don't
even know if it was during round top
that defense but at some point the
soldiers from maine the colors were lost
for a little while and chamberlain wants
to address that directly
to the surviving troops in this in this
speech
and i just want to read one section of
it
he says
your colors
it was said were lost
that word came to me when on the morning
of the second i reached the crest far to
the rear
of that where you had stood
and i felt a shock but not of shame
for i knew something terrible must have
befallen
and that there could have been no
dishonor where you were
but when i came to know the truth of it
all i saw that instead of your colors
being lost they were eternally saved
[Music]
not laid down but lifted up
not captured nor surrendered but
translated the shadow lost in substance
the flag
it is the symbol of the country's honor
power law and life
it is the ensign of loyalty the bond of
brotherhood for those who stand under it
a token and an inspiration
hence it is held sacred by the soldier
as in great moments it is also by the
citizen
all which that flag symbolized
you had illustrated and impersonated had
absorbed into your thoughts and hearts
if i should not rather say itself had
absorbed your thoughts and hearts your
service and suffering into its own
deeper meaning and dearer honor
now it had done all a simple could do
you had stood
for it all
now the supreme moment had come nothing
could be averted nothing could be
resisted nothing could be escaped that
was an awful moment passing that of
death it seems to me
then a new soul is born
no thought of yielding
up the token of the country's honor
enters the heart of any one of you
though it has fulfilled its ends
though you are to go to prison and death
your colonel
calm and dauntless commander still bids
you break the staff that are born at
aloft and tear that symbol single as
your souls into many pieces as you had
bosoms and shelter them with your lives
lest that flag be touched by hostile
hand or triumphed over living man
lost
there is a way of losing
that is finding
when soul
over masters sense when the noble and
divine self overcomes the lower self
when duty and honor and love immortal
things
bid the mortal perish
it is only when a man supremely gives
that he supremely finds
that was your sacrifice
that
is your reward
when we talked about the surrender
it was him describing it and you know
later parts of the book
you find out
that that salute that they gave to the
confederates
they weren't ordered to do that he just
straight up did that out of chivalry
and then as the confederates are coming
past
and they think that the you know they're
like ah man you know their heads are
down
and they see that you know
they think the union armories are making
fun of them or laughing at them or
scoffing at them
and they receive that salute
and they give the salute
back it's just incredible incredible
description yeah
yeah it's um
i don't know what else i can do um
do the do the audio book i think at some
point just freaking sit here and read
this whole thing
in your best main accent yeah my best
main accent i'll also work i i apologize
that sometimes i pronounce words wrong
and i'm sorry
i'm just kind of reading it and i don't
feel like doing nine takes to say words
that i can't say very well so i
apologize
about that that i don't do that justice
but so many lessons in this book
um just about how to be a good human
being and i i i still i know we just did
two podcasts on on it but it's
there's so much in there this guy is
such an incredible example the way he
lived
uh the things he did his attitude
and really you know
some people talk about the divisiveness
you know in america right now and you
know you hear people say oh it's never
been this bad before well you know what
it has it's been freaking infinitely
worse infinitely worse
and
the fact that you could go through a
divisiveness
so incredibly
incredibly violent
i mean this is our war where we just
just it was a slaughter
think about that last podcast the things
that the descriptions he's giving on
those battlefields but if we as a nation
can go through that
that that insane
violence
and at the end of that
at the end of that at the end of killing
each other
wholesale slaughtering each other at the
end of that
the very men that
that fought each other that killed each
other those very men
can stand
and salute each other
and
respect each other
and decide
that we should stay a union
if we as a country can get through that
then
i only can hope
that we can
move past
some of the bickering that we have today
and hold up this flag
and unify all of us together
to continue to provide a place in the
world
with freedom
for all
so thanks for listening
um thanks for your support
in what we're doing
like i said if you want to come out you
want to hang out with myself and jason
and the rest of the echelon front team
you want to
walk these battlefields
um
you want to feel some freaking emotions
you want to have a spiritual experience
come and check out these events that we
do
we got
in may the 11th and 12th and may the
13th and 14th of gettysburg and we're
going
also to little bighorn in august
16th 17th and then another session 18th
and 19th
come and check it out if you can't go
with us and read these books
think about what these people went
through
think about what they overcame it's um
it's history and we should never forget
we should never forget this this history
that we have in this country
and
what we've been through we've been
through a ton
we can't forget that should keep us
together
what else echo charles
we need to be this is the old school
decompression scenario
uh actually the uh small thing i thought
it's not not quite as serious but i will
say this so you know it's what is it
about
when you have like enemies right
or even people who just don't like each
other no one any form of like enemy and
then they go through like all this like
ups and downs and they fight each other
or and
and then at the end like they become
friends or whatever maybe they reconcile
and they become friends but what is it
about that that makes everyone feel so
good afterwards
uh i would say part of it is the shared
struggle right
you've been through some [__] i've been
through some [__] okay
like
there's a shared struggle even if we're
not opposing it i mean you think of a
football game right you play a good game
against someone and it's a scrap
and you're throwing down and it's muddy
and it's close like
when you say good game to that person
you mean it right you mean it absolutely
so i think that shared struggle and then
you know like part of it has got to be
like thank god this is over you know i
got that feeling from the southern
soldiers that they were like thank god
this is over like i'm done yeah and i
mean
and
there's an opportunity for redemption
right when when you're fighting someone
and they're your enemy and then at the
end of it we're like hey
we're not enemies anymore
right
there's the redemption there's an end to
it because if we keep holding that
animosity it never ends yeah
and there's no there's no healing
there's nothing else like that and so
like you know you didn't cover it but
like
there's what you did where they're
sharing their meals but they were they
were trading stuff for like there was
like an intermingling there for a couple
hours where they were trading souvenirs
with one another and that's incredible
when you're talking about men that and a
couple hours before that
had walked all freaking night and part
of the day to kill one another and now
they're just like oh we're done yeah and
by the way they just killed each other a
week before that and a month before that
and six months before that you know this
is just a bloody bloody awful
awful war it's so it's like the
christmas story in world war one yeah
it's an indicator that we're not
bad
yep it's it's one of those things where
these these these you know great things
happens and it indicates that we're just
we're
not
like sure we're flawed as human beings
but we're not flawed beyond redemption
and i think the the the thing that i get
out of
like the the christmas truce
and this ceremony here at the end is
it's just that
not that we're not even i don't i i
don't know if we're not bad or not i
definitely indicates that we're not
right it indicates but also
it indicates to me that
we all have way more in common than we
have not in common and like
when you get to the point at the end of
the day jason gardner has to eat
has to [__]
has to make money has to feed his family
has to help out with you know what
you're doing in the world and i'm over
here i have to eat i have to [__] i have
to take care of my family and i want my
kids to have a good life and you want
your kids to have a good life and i
don't want you know i want to have some
kind of stability in my life and you
want to have some kind of stability in
your life and so we
we we have so much in common
and we let things that are sort of
oftentimes
if you put them in a bigger picture
totally irrelevant i mean that's what
was shocking about the brits and the
germans having a freak pl up playing
soccer
is
like
those guys didn't give a [__] what was
going on with some freaking king
somewhere
they didn't care they're like what i i
why do i care about this land over here
in france i live in germany bro
you live in england like i don't care
the french people lived here let them
live here what are we doing
we get wrapped around some dumb [__]
and
you know in this case it it's
definitely
a a very distinct
reason for fighting
and the union had to go through this
turmoil to
rid itself of
slavery
had to go through it there was no other
way it wasn't gonna it wasn't gonna go
easy you had to do this kind of
massive war
to get to get through that
um but we did
and now we can go get stuff from
originusa.com
you're supposed to come in and like help
bro you're supposed to say some [__]
like that to like make me cough power
over here that was a rough rough
transition
but i think it is like it's like um like
after you fight for so long it's almost
like you lose
you almost forget kind of
like these men like minimal things that
or evidently minimal things that you're
quote unquote fighting for and you start
remembering all the commonality stuff
and then you start to get kind of
exhausted in a way where you're like
just like i said like what are we doing
like you kind of forget what you're
fighting for you're just so habitually
caught up in the fight and then finally
when you it's almost like you kind of
snapped him and be like wait a second
like we're fighting over something super
small but meanwhile we have all these
commonalities that are so big
and then it's like a fight it's like a
relief you know and i think even when
you engage in a battle
what do you call it when two other
people battle and you're just witnessing
it and you see them battling you're
taking this guy aside then you're taking
this guy's side or whatever and then
they finally make up you kind of feel
good too for some reason like you ever
seen like a rivalry end between some
people it like feels kind of good yeah
yeah i uh sometimes i've gotten asked a
couple times like do i would i want to
go back to iraq and like and i
not there yet at all
i'm not like hey let's check it out
check the battlefield in ramadi look at
go look at baghdad like i'm not there
i'm not i don't have any desire to do
that
i don't know if i'll get there yeah
ramon is just like rubble anyway
they're not rebuilding it at all i don't
know but i think when
liberating it from isis didn't yeah
although i saw those videos it was
freaking
rubble yeah
house by house like oh there might be
bad guys in there nuke it
yeah
um
i
i don't know when you had holly mackey
on and she talked about afghanistan
falling and then then um you know the
story about the two the taliban guys who
slept outside of her hotel room because
they were they wanted to protect her
so even
they're our enemy and and and and you
can see your enemies acting with with
honor and i think that was definitely
honorable because i didn't think that
was going to work out that well for her
when i heard that story i'm like how did
you even make it back i know
when she was over there i was like it
might be a good time to leave it might
be good like you're not gonna be able to
leave now you know hell might you should
probably leave you should probably leave
oh you're not gonna be able to get out
there and she got out of there
boy she's a brave woman
i i asked him like do you think he may
be a little naive she's like yeah maybe
you know i wouldn't be rolling around in
there
maybe i'm too paranoid
maybe i'm too risk-averse
wait did you just see one too many
videos yeah
somebody in an orange jumpsuit somewhere
they weren't supposed to be and you're
just like
god
um
all right what else echo speaking of
videos
origin usa
you got some cool videos on their
youtube channel
if you're interested you can see how all
the american-made stuff is made
including jocko fuel by the way
yep and guess what we uh at origin maine
have unified
the north and the south we have uh we
have factories up in maine we have
factories in north carolina we're all on
the same team the american team
the healing is continued
the healing continues
uh i haven't been down to the north
carolina factory i'm looking forward to
getting down there and meeting everyone
i got i got some roots in north carolina
and you know i obviously have the root
the new england roots new england uh
who's your roots just on the uh on my
mom's side yeah i was born there i got
some roots in south carolina
you do dead side yeah
beautiful state true story yeah you
you're you're a straight-up uh
uh descendant of slaves correct from
south carolina south carolina yeah
that uh
at the end of the civil war
about 10
of the union army
was
former slaves that had escaped to the
north and if you think about that number
10 of the union army that means
basically every able-bodied
former slave man
straight up just went and fought
freaking legit yeah that's freaking
legit
um
yeah speaking of legit look okay we'll
talk about some energy drinks legitimate
not illegitimate
cause that's a stigma that energy drinks
used to have we don't have that anymore
choco go healthy energy drink jason you
know about this i heard you last time
you hear me
um uh also a lot of other good
supplements again
american-made stuff yep good supplements
go to jackalful.com got some taste good
protein got some uh joint health stuff
i'm i'm and you kind of need a bulk
right now to be honest
do you get do you get taught you get i
don't know what the word is because last
time we talked about jiu jitsu post jiu
jitsu fatigue sets in right hour and a
half after jiu jitsu tired
you leave jiu jitsu wired kind of like
amped hyped
by the time you get home
if you get home and then you eat you're
you're going into some serious like
sleep mode
same thing with the podcast like i get
done with the podcast i'm super freaking
hyped for like an hour and a half oh
yeah yeah maybe two hours and then all
this no it's not an hour it's not two
hours i got like an hour and a half of
energy i'll usually try and go home and
start prepping my next podcast
because i know i have energy that i need
to do something with
but then
it's mentally taxing
to think and read and react and you're
so like deep into it
and you're getting emotional i'm
freaking getting emotional reading a
freaking book today right like
that's all happening
what does that mean
is if i'm getting emotional reading a
book is that taking the same emotional
toll or having the same emotional impact
as it is if i
watch a movie
is it the same as if it if i have like
something happen in my life what's the
difference probably the movie's probably
similar not in life because life kind of
like the emotional part of life kind of
continues right because your life is
actually the movie it ends and you're
like cool story
book i mean even though this one's true
it's like okay that story is kind of
done so yeah but like
there's an emotion of pride that i feel
when i hear these stories that again
when i when i see my kid like doing
something or someone that i'm proud for
them it's kind of it's almost the same
experience but it is
a shorter burn for sure yeah for sure
well that you know this it's like this
is always gonna be the case this
happened no matter what happens from now
you know kind of thing but when you read
the book it kind of calls your attention
to it you know and that's what's gonna
invoke these emotions same thing with
the movie but when i read this book or
books like this i'm having
the emotions that i'm feeling are
probably one-third the motion from the
book and two-thirds emotion of my own
memories yeah and that's how movies are
too right like
like i get them like i think about these
situations that unfolded and i'm
thinking about situations that unfolded
for me obviously not to the degree of
but
you know like
you can't help thinking about that stuff
and so
even though it
it it it comes quick and then you can
close the book and it's over but you
still were in there yeah
that's uh so i'll be freaking sleep like
a baby tonight yeah after your milk
shake yeah after half a time that's what
i was saying because the milkshake also
just stimulates like
a form of pleasure
pleasure centers and of of uh
of of safety and
comfort comfort yeah you know you have a
mulk and you're kind of like bro it's
all good you know the world's good it
kind of kind of takes you to a
psychological area where things are good
like there's no you're not storming up a
blood-soaked hill
and drinking a mulch no no those are the
onions of the spectrum
so i'll go have a mulk as like a way to
wind down a little bit sure enter the
zone the milk zone
so there you go
uh check it out jogglefuel.com
originusa.com jockle store we sell
shirts at joggle store yep right shirts
hats he's merch if you will
some new stuff on there what's up with
the grays against the machine shirt that
you're wearing is it like a group is it
just no man it's sandwich it's a it's a
uh a buddy of mine that's into
regenerative ag oh sweet had the shirt
made up grays against the machine what
if people want to order one what's the
guy that watches i don't even know if
they make them anymore yeah just got it
yeah i will figure it we'll figure that
out and post something in the notes yeah
we can throw him up if we want to make
him if he wants to make him or whatever
um
uh
subscribe to the punk jackal
underground.com
once again i don't know what's getting i
don't know who's getting shut down for
what
uh
i don't know what there's some crazy
stuff going on in canada right now
people are getting shut down they're
getting their finances halted
that's what's happening right now this
isn't like me talking about some
dystopian future where things have gone
awry
what's happening in canada they're doing
that without court order and all that
other scary stuff so that's kind of
crazy yes
i don't know what's going to happen here
but if it happens we're going to be on
the underground if you want to help us
out there
uh
jockowunderground.com go subscribe it
costs eight dollars and eighteen cents a
month if you can't afford that we're not
casting you out of the zone of freedom
no you just have to email assistants at
jacquelineground.com youtube channel
check that out it's true
psychological warfare flipside canvas
dakota meyer
making cool stuff to hang on your wall
i've written a bunch of books about
leadership you can also get bayonet
forward if you want to get these books
you can go to
jacopodcast.com go to books on the
podcast books from episode 2
and they're all there
they're kind of a list in order of the
books i recommend you read
now would all things being if i was to
restack that book that that
thing would they be adjusted a little
bit there'd be some adjustments
this book would be further up there i
was never a huge
civil war guy
until probably like five years ago i
don't know it seemed like it was too far
ago whatever
um no like don't get me wrong it's not
like i wasn't interested in the civil
war at all but i wasn't go i didn't
start going deep
not like you know for me it was always
kind of number one nom closest memory
number two world war ii number three
korea because
we didn't hear as much about that as we
needed to
so the civil war there's been people
asking me about the civil war i've got a
stack of books stack of books
ready for
the podcast that i
this is the one we're starting with i
guess
um
oh yeah so you can get all that stuff at
jackopodcast.com
we have a leadership consultancy
if you want to check that out we talk
about leadership not just in war in fact
very little in war now it's about
business
so go to echelonfront.com for that we
have an online training academy go to
streamownership.com if you have a
question about any of this and you want
to ask jason gardner or you want to ask
me or you want to ask leif
or any of us jp dannell you want to ask
him something go to
extremeownership.com and you can go onto
one of our
zoom sessions you can just ask away you
can ask 19 questions if you want to yeah
and then there's a bunch of other people
who are in the game and on the path yeah
and you can hear the questions they're
asking because they probably have the
same pro and they do they have the same
problems you do yep yep it's fantastic
so that's extremeownership.com and then
we have some charities america's
mightywarriors.org doing great stuff by
mama lee markley's mom and then also
heroes and horses.com
check that one out both these
organizations looking to help out uh
people who have served
and if you want to hear more from us
we're on social media
which means in in order to enter that
you got to go you got to go play russian
roulette with the algorithm
it's more like dodgeball to be honest
okay
you know you can you know you can have
some fun with it for sure but yeah you
get if that thing gets ahead of you yeah
you get caught up in a spiral they're
not letting that happen in china by the
way
because their
kids aren't allowed to be on after such
and such a time and the things that
they're allowed to look at are
controlled by the state
now i don't support controlling things
by the state certainly
but
if you don't pay attention
you can waste
45 minutes on social media 45 minutes
you wind up you're like hey what is my
thumb doing why did it just go right
there hit instagram and now i'm sweeping
past i'm like oh stop it yeah yeah
that's the algorithms guys
echo's trying to defend the algorithm
last time no no no no the algorithm is
like fire
right it's like fire it's okay you can
use it if you use it in a controlled way
but it can really easy catch catch hold
your whole household everything's
burning everything's on fire very so be
careful
jason
on instagram he's at jason.n
gardner
and on twitter he's jason and gardner
and
on the twitter on the gram and on the
facebook people
echoes out equal charles i am at
jocko willink
and
of course thanks to all the military
personnel out there
for
holding
us
safe here in the world holding up the
flag
and doing your best to represent the
ideals
so everyone can see
we appreciate that
and of course here at home thanks to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
all the first responders thank you for
what you do
here at home to keep us safe
and until
next time remember
that there is a way of losing
that is finding
and as joshua chamberlain said it is
only when a man supremely gives
that he supremely finds
so go out there
and give
and until next time
this is jason an echo and jocko